so
[Music]
do
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
welcome to the mother of all talk shows
the open
university of the airwaves the college
of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees and where you
are positively encouraged to speak back
to the teacher
this is the biggest show of its kind
in the entire world more than a
million viewers of the mother of all
talk shows
but are there bigger shows in other
worlds
are there other worlds with intelligent
life
on them is there intelligent life on
this
world these are some of the issues we're
going to be
exploring if i can make that
pun in the course of the next three
hours
we'll be talking to a real spaceman
he is of course joe biden not him
personally
but caleb mopan who understands them
more clearly
than virtually anybody else we'll be
talking
about another space man an alien
being to some boris johnson the british
prime minister
he found love in a very
very hopeless place we'll be talking
about that and how it has wrong-footed
everyone it's the mother of all talk
shows three hours
radio sputnik we speak your language the
mother of all talk shows
the only education you can get for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
and this is london but coming to you of
course all over the world
thanks to the wonders of the internet
and sputniknews.com
in the washington dc area you can
listen to us in fm on 105.5
fm across the united states on am
from burning city to burning city across
the entire world
you can listen to us on the
aforementioned
sputniknews.com but if you are one
of the one million people who
watch as well as listen then
listen to this if you are watching us
on facebook please share it right now
with all of your friends all of your
contacts if you are watching us on
youtube
either my youtube channel or rt's
multiple youtube channels then please
do subscribe and if you're watching on
instagram on twitter as an ever growing
number of you
are watching on your telephones who knew
5g would work not me then
you are very welcome to you can watch on
my telegram channel
can watch on twitch all kinds of
platforms
are now carrying this the biggest
politics show in the world get your head
around that
and if you knew the budget on which we'd
do it
you'd laugh i cry but you would
laugh a million people watching a show
from across the world that's us you're
one of them
that proves you are intelligent
life is there intelligent life in space
and are they sending craft to bother us
we'll be talking about that how will we
identify
that intelligent life well we'll be
talking to the regis
professor of chemistry from the
university of glasgow
in my former parliamentary constituency
my first parliamentary constituency
where i would still have been if tony
blair had not expelled me
over the iraq war and then abolished my
constituency
just in case something to which i may
return if i've got time but first it
would be
churlish and i am not a churro
not to wish every happiness to the newly
wedded mr
and mrs boris johnson they
found love in a hopeless place
he was with somebody else in fact he was
married to somebody else
and with somebody else she was with
somebody else but they found love and
those of us
like myself who have found love
know how precious and important that is
so i wish
the couple all the best i don't agree
with
hardly anything that they stand for
maybe one or two things
but i am not one of those
who thinks that one should automatically
hate those with whom one disagrees
if that were the case a lot of the
people watching this show
wouldn't be watching it and that is
an important lesson the purpose of this
show
is to be a university so that we can all
learn
from each other i learn from your calls
from the things that you write to me not
from all of them
of course and you learn i hope
either to agree or disagree with what i
stand for
through this medium of the mother of
all talk shows speaking of hate
there's a labour mp or ex-labor mp
in scotland they're almost all ex-labor
mps
there's only one labour mp in scotland
now
but when there were more than 50 of us
there was one called tom harris
he was a glasgow mp like me he seems to
think i hated him though i never did
but since losing office tom has become
something of a celebrated newspaper
columnist and he damned me with fake
praise
in his daily telegraph column just a day
or two
ago if you're behind the paywall you
might be able to
read it if not i'll summarize it
according to tom in a very well written
article if i hadn't stood for
what i actually do stand for
i would have been the leader of the
labour party
and the candidate therefore to be prime
minister
of great britain of course he misses the
point
that if i did not stand for
what i do stand for i wouldn't be
me he doesn't go into details
about the offensive his word things that
i do
stand for that have stopped me becoming
the leader of the labour party so i'll
do it
for him he means i presume
the vehemence with which i opposed the
war
in iraq a war which every
sentient being on the planet and i'm
sure
anybody that is sentient on any other
planet
already now knows was a complete
and unmitigated disaster unmitigated
disaster everybody on this planet
with two brain cells two robbed together
already knows that i was right about the
invasion
and occupation of iraq and tony blair
about whom more later was
wrong although wrong would be to put it
very
kindly indeed everything i said
about the iraq war turned out to be true
and
everything that tony blair and george
bush
said about the iraq war turned out to be
false except where it was a deliberate
falsehood a lie and we
all know what i'm talking about
i could do no other than oppose
the iraq war because i knew that they
were lying
i could do no other than to oppose the
iraq war because i knew
that it would end in the catastrophic
swamp of blood and death and suffering
that it has ended in what kind of person
would
i be if knowing these things
i had kept well one of the things i
might be
according to big tom is the leader of
the labour party but
what would be the point of being the
leader of the labour party
if one had deliberately sublimated
that which they knew to be true in the
interests of opportunism
understand this tom and others
i don't say and do what i do to be
popular
i don't say and do what i do
in the hope that it will be profitable
i say and do what i do because
i believe it to be right
and of course i paid a price for that
though not the price
they expected me to pay when tony blair
expelled me from the labour party
in 2005 he thought he would never see my
face
again never hear my voice again
but actually he's had to look at my face
more since he expelled me than he ever
did
before he did so he's had to listen to
me
i promised him from the steps of the
place where i was being expelled
in king's cross that he would rule the
day
the labour party would rule the day
that they expelled me over the iraq war
and i've made them
ruined twice already
capturing two rock-solid
labor parliamentary constituencies
and i intend to do so again
not because i need a job i've got more
jobs than i can handle now
not because i need the money i'm in no
need of
money but because i am determined
that the things i stand for opposition
to imperialist
war the
grand larceny of the country that used
to be called
palestine and the suffering of its
millions of citizens scattered to the
four
corners of the earth just as well they
can't
put them in a spaceship and send them to
another world
because if they could they would
i cannot remain silent about these
things
because i believe them and i am one of
these strange
political beasts that does things
because they believe them and guess what
millions of other people believe them
also millions of us marched against the
war
in iraq millions of us are marching now
in defense of the palestinian people in
gaza
and when the attention shifts as it will
as i've long promised you to jerusalem
itself
to the repeated invasion
of the al-aqsa mosque
one of the holiest of shrines
in islam just yards from the church
of the holy sepulchre where jesus
was laid trust me
there will be tens if not hundreds of
millions
on the march on the move
now netanyahu has just followed and
you're just about to find out
as gideon levy the greatest living as
israeli
told you on this show just a couple of
weeks ago
the problem was not netanyahu
as a matter of fact the two people who
are about to take over
from netanyahu are even worse
than him was that netanyahu
imagine who could imagine
but we're about to find out that what
i'm saying
is true it wasn't netanyahu that
designed
the catastrophe that the palestinian
people have been suffering
for more than a hundred years now
living under occupation
since 1948 since 1967
living as refugees since 1948
since 1967 since 1970
when they were driven out of jordan
people that i know people that i love
that live in the most rancid
misery don't expect me to
forget them don't expect me to turn my
back on them
i'm not that kind of man
i will never turn my back on people that
i have
promised promised to their face
i that i will
use every breath that god gives me
to try to come to their side
and i shall continue to do so on all
platforms
on radio on television in print in
parliament
on streets in squares
through loud hailers or microphones
or through this camera reaching more
than a million
viewers just on this show alone
now we'll be talking in the course of
tonight to the live wire patrick
christie
about how
unbelievably with one bound boris
johnson was free
if you were watching dominic
whom the liberal media had told us
just a year ago was
possibly mephistopheles himself
beelzebub dominic cummings the liar
has been transformed into a liberal
icon because he has
turned big time against his former
friend
and boss boris johnson
well comfortably i sit
being against dominic cummings and boris
johnson
not in the last year but always in every
year
i can say that when i listened to
cummings talking
i think it was for 10 hours
i thought that boris johnson might be
in serious trouble and here we are on
sunday and no one is
even talking about it like the wallpaper
gate
that went before it it's an attack that
has
failed the conservative party
is now ahead in the public opinion polls
for the 85th poll
in a row and here
is one of the most salient features
of those opinion polls
more than twice as many working-class
people are placing their trust
in boris johnson than in the labor
leader kirsten i've been saying here for
months
long before there was a by-election
in which i would be a candidate
that kier starmer is quite the worst
leader of an opposition that i have
ever seen and i saw ian duncan smith
i saw michael howard
i've seen terrible opposition leaders
but i've never seen one as bad as
keerstarman he's so wooden
the birds are trying to nest in him
so wooden people are hammering in nails
to him i'll tell you what
he can't take much more he can't
take much more in terms of by-election
defeats
catastrophic public opinion poll
ratings he can't take much more
when a leader is being caught
in a pincer movement from
the blairites on the right
to the carbonites on the left
he is not much longer for the leadership
of the labour party and i'm going to
make
a bold prediction to you
kyrstarma will spend his summer holidays
on a beach reflecting
that he is now the ex-leader of the
labour party
the ex-leader of the opposition
and i hope to play some part in bringing
that about who the labour party puts in
his place
might not be any more politically
acceptable to me
just like naphtali bennett
who's now about to take the place of
netanyahu
just because i'm against one doesn't
mean i'm for the other
i'll probably not be for the next labor
leader
either but britain needs an
opposition parliament needs an
opposition democracy cannot operate
when the opposition is struck
deaf dumb and blind represents
nothing and nobody is a cipher
rather than an opposition british
democracy cannot
afford that and that's why
for britain i say kierstarma
must go let me launch the poll
is there intelligent life in
a space b earth
c nowhere
who writes this stuff that's a good one
actually you can
write to me in the
in my uh twitter profile
now it's my twitter by the way at george
galloway
that's where that poll is but it's also
on
telegram isn't it and uh you can vote
there
too now i'm supposed to ask you a trivia
question but
nobody gave it to me
uh now
i'm supposed to ask you a trivia
question but nobody
gave it to me that's just the way it
goes
let me take a 60 second break
radio sputnik
[Music]
i've just i've just left
let's take a call go ahead kenny hi
george here i just want to talk about
the trans issue that you were speaking
about earlier
in front of me by uh douglas murray and
he's got a paragraph here
just like that we do if that's okay oh
yeah go ahead okay
i was standing on the corner
all right i'll get him off get him off
he's a nutter he's a nutter
in the uk it's 0 8 0 8
1 9 6 5 5 2
2 and in the u.s it's plus one eight
four four
nine four four double three double four
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have
as long as you have questions we'll keep
asking
radio sputnik telling the untold
now on this day in 1990
1990 france initiated
a trade boycott on this
british product was it a
whiskey b black pudding
or c beef you can let me know there are
no prizes
but you might be interested in letting
me know
now darren stanton otherwise known as
the human lie
detector is britain's leading body
language expert
dharam began his uk television and media
career
back in 2010 when he was asked to assess
the politicians during the tv live
debate
for the general election prior to this
darren spent his days
investigating and dealing with liars
cheats and criminals as a house of
connor as a
police officer since then darren has
been a regular
on our tv screens and on radio
with appearances on some of britain's
biggest shows
including my own shows sputnik and
the mother of all talk shows now
darren is going to join me now to talk
about dominic cummings
dara you must have watched because
the whole country was watching you must
have watched if not
all then parts of dominic cummings
epic parliamentary performance this week
what did you think of his performance
what did his body language
say to you yeah i watched it obviously
quite a lot a lot of times and
it was fascinating because we saw a
total
reverb reversal we saw a total change
from when we saw the
the famous rose garden press conference
um
a year ago yes yes what difference a
year can make
then he was a demon now he's the uh
he's the hero of the liberal classes
it's just intrigued me out somebody
suddenly everyone's done a u-turn now
what appears to the u-turn and said that
you know he's now this paragon of virtue
that's come out
and been totally honest and stuff but
there's i mean again going back to last
year there was lots of things that
you know i wasn't happy about in terms
of where you conveyed it but
um for the for the launch part um of
this press conference
um last week we we saw a lot of gestures
which were consistent with
with him being sort of been honest now
there's two schools of thought on this
either he's convinced himself of what
the truth is
in which case the body follows what we
believe or indeed you know he's being
completely truthful but it's
been fascinating to see the change in
terms of how he conveys himself
tell us what he did what he manifested
that made you think he might very well
be telling the truth
well when someone's being basically
afraid of being discovered in quite a
big lie the biggest fear is the
consequence and what people tend to do
no matter how well they're trained
and again as you know i've assessed some
of the biggest um
celebrities and politicians um you know
that we know and
last year um it was very very um
unanimated so he was almost withdrawn
into himself
in terms of his posture he wasn't making
many hand gestures
and he blink rape was was was kind of
double or triple which are
all what i call red flags now with the
press conference last week
we saw lots of what we call open palm
gesture which
psychologically saying you know i have
no weapons it's almost like saying
i'm being truthful his blink rate didn't
spike
on certain parts of where i would ever
have expected it to
to do so um and dems the way that he
conveyed himself verbally
um people tend to have quite a high
pitch
or their voice cracks um from the
anxiety and
you know i didn't pick up too much of
that with him so again
he's either convinced himself of a of a
backstory
to such a high degree that he believes
it now or he's been truthful
he spoke for such a long time i mean
even i would struggle with a 10 hour
uh a 10-hour parliamentary
statement it was a committee that was
grilling him
did he seem confident in what he was
saying
did he seem at all fearful
yes a great question george and there's
a number of key things i
i picked up on and again you know if
many of us imagine you know seven hours
it's it's a bit of an ordeal
but he he was consistent in his behavior
um throughout that period but there are
a couple of interesting things that
he tended to make the gesture we put he
put his hands on his head
at certain times and that's what we call
a self-reassurance gesture
like a self-hug what do you mean what do
you mean on his head on top of his head
or back on his head yeah you know
sometimes they might see a child or
somebody might do it in frustration
yeah but they put their hands on the
head yeah now he did that at a number of
significant points where he you know he
realized that
what he was saying was going to be quite
dumbing for for for the p.m and hancock
you know so obviously when he said about
the lies if people watch that back
you know he makes a quite a number of
these gestures where he self touches
his his face and his head um
did you find that convincing i did to be
fair because that's not a gesture
that he's made before although we've not
seen him give a lot
you know a lot of press conferences and
he's not made that gesture before so for
example anything that's
new or different or something that
someone
uh not not just doesn't normally do that
that flags up to me
so that did seem quite convincing the
fact that he realized the
kind of importance and the impact of
what he was saying
well i mean on the face of it it could
scarcely have been more
important he was effectively accusing
uh his former boss the prime minister of
britain
of having caused the deaths
of thousands maybe tens of thousands of
people
unnecessarily now that is verging
on an allegation of criminal
negligence yeah absolutely and i think
when he was asked the question i think
it was
jeremy asked a question um about you
know are you not sort of
i can't remember the the phrase he used
but essentially he was asking
um cummings you know are you not sort of
disgusted almost that you didn't pull
the rip called
long before that and he pretty much said
yes i am um and then when he when he was
also pushed on
you know have you got any evidence that
you've said that matt hancock has been
lying
he said yeah you know i've got i've got
whatsapp messages i've got i've got
emails available
i'll make that available to the
committee so that would have been a key
point in which i would have expected
someone that's been
less than honest to who have begun to
stutter or begin to destroy
yes but he didn't he was it was it was
called a cucumber to be honest george
now uh what about the uh moment where he
apologized for his
own shortcomings uh um if you'll forgive
the pun uh
he wasn't uh able to it would have been
scarcely
credible considering how central he was
to the government's coronavirus response
he didn't spare himself in the
criticism did he was that persuasive
i think it was i mean he made no
attempts to sort of deflect any of the
questions
or like he said to this because normally
what i find when i assess politicians is
they will distance themselves and they
will tend to use
phraseology like yes you know well those
people or
when that happened they'll they'll sort
of create this disassociation
as if it's a separate issue so for
example the famous expression with
clinton
you know i didn't have relations with
that woman even though we knew
you know the truth so we didn't see any
of that sort of language or behavior
depends what you mean by relations
doesn't it he was relying on a very uh
rather uh arcane and obscure point
about what relations would constitute
um not that cummings would be involved
in any of that stuff
did he flag in any way did he keep it up
right to the end
so another key thing which i thought was
interesting was when he was quizzed
about
the whole debacle about going up to
durham um
i mean you know far better than me in
terms of what security would have been
available for him
have there been credible threats but i
think that was he wasn't giving us the
whole story on that because we see what
we call
it's almost like a reverse horseshoe so
if you imagine sort of like your
you make an expression of indifference
almost but it's like an upside down
horseshoe
with your mouth um and that is that is
um
not a deceptive tell but it's something
that kind of flies to me that
maybe he couldn't give the whole truth
but he was i think he was certainly
holding something back
i don't think we've been told the full
story on the whole situation with
regards to
to break in the corona rules he could of
course
be a psychopathic liar and this
could of course all be about the fact
that
he fell out of love with boris johnson
or
boris fell out of love with him
did you see any signs that that might be
the explanation i didn't see any sounds
that he's got sort of sociopathic or
psychopathic tendencies but
you know you're quite right i mean the
the people that tend to be able to beat
these
these kind of analysis and polygraph as
you know or people with personality
disorders
and and people with psychopathics or
tendencies that
that can convince themselves of whatever
reality they like
and indeed they will they will come over
completely credible
so so yeah you know well you see i asked
because that's exactly what he was being
described as
just a year ago by in many cases
the very same correspondence
that are now behaving as if he has
brought down
on tablets of stone from the mount
the whole and unvarnished truth
i'm thinking of the sky news uh lady
beth rigby who was
cummings chief persecutor a year ago
and you remember those scenes outside
his house
they were treating him as if he was a
criminal indeed they were treating him
as
a criminal just a year ago and now
everything has completely transformed
so i suppose
it's not really your place to answer but
if you've got an answer i'd love to hear
it
which was the real dominic cummings
last year's model or this year's model
it's it's really interesting you bring
up that journalist because i know she's
she's been quite forthright and i'm
again i looked at all the daily
briefings
throughout the whole year and you know
interesting at the time no one would
take my analysis
because there's quite a lot of things
that were flagging up during the daily
briefings
but um my personal instinct george is
that
last year is the true cummins is if i
thought my honest opinion
okay so no stammering
the reverse horseshoe the blink rate
the hands on the head it sounds like a
bravura
performance i suppose the acid test is
was it a performance or was it
the real deal was it the real thing
i thought when i read and heard
the headlines that he had put boris
johnson in a very very difficult place
but it's only sunday and boris is
celebrating his
nuptials and everyone's forgotten about
dominic cummings
i wonder if this was a good day
for boris to bury that bad news
you know what honestly that that is
exactly
i was interested a few other times
yesterday and i i kind of said the same
thing
it was it just seems quite strategic i
don't know in a way
because i'm an old cynic so i think it
seems a bit strategic
that all these things have happened in
the space of a few days and like you say
it does seem a good day to bury bad news
doesn't it and it's buried
i mean if that was the intention it's
worked
they say that boris is a fool but he's
the wisest fool in christendom
thanks uh darren stanton the human lie
detector
thank you very much indeed for joining
us
on the mother of all talk shows now let
me give you the
telephone number which is
remember it's free now toll free from
the united states
it's entirely free from the united
kingdom
uh so if you're in the uk it's
808 1 96 double five double two
that's 808 one sorry
uh i wish this could be written properly
081 five
five two two that's oh eight oh eight
one
nine six five five two two if you're in
the united states
it's plus one eight four four
nine four four double three double four
and you can tweet us of course at george
galloway
at rt uk news
let's take
oh there's another trivia
well i better give you the answer to the
first one
on this day in 1990 france initiated a
trade boycott
on which british product was it a
whiskey
b black pudding or c
beef well i knew that it wouldn't be
black pudding
because i don't think the french palate
could quite take black pudding
and i kind of guessed it wouldn't be
whiskey because
with all the wine and things that
they've got and their own spirits
do they drink that much whiskey so i was
sure it would be beef
and beef it was so here's the second
question
in this week in 1957 a famous
us playwright was found guilty of
contempt by congress for refusing
to name communists was it
arthur miller eugene o'neill
or tennessee williams i'll give you an
answer to that
after the break 66.
radio sputnik
[Music]
gosh darn how do you get this thing to
work
did that one is it is it this one here
gosh was this thing built in america
jeez kamala would you
get in here i can't get the
uh gosh darn wireless to work
you know i can't answer questions joe
when i'm laughing
i'm trying to uh listen to that
scottish guy on the wireless the uh
the galloway fella oh joe you're so
funny
[Music]
i've been pressing this red button on
and off and on
and off heck i can't get it to work
uh hello biden residents
mr president be advised we have executed
the airstrike on syria
that's just great uh how long until it
gets delivered i'm
starving
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
which famous u.s playwright was found
guilty in 1957
of contempt of congress for refusing to
name
names in front of the committee was it
arthur miller
eugene o'neill or tennessee williams the
answer
is the great arthur miller
now there wasn't much sign of
intelligent life
in the congress of the united states in
but the congress and indeed the former
president of the united states barack
obama
are increasingly hinting
more than hinting that there is big
news in their possession about the
existence
of unidentified flying objects
they haven't gone as far as to say that
these objects
were evidence of extraterrestrial life
but it's quite difficult to understand
what they would be if not that
you probably didn't know i was sitting
in parliament for decades
and not knowing that the ministry of
defense
in britain as in the united states
had a ufo department and
the man that ran it was nick pope
who joins me now nick
welcome back to the mother of all talk
shows it's always a pleasure
the proximate reason for asking you
on now again is because
barack obama seemed to indicate that he
knew things he hasn't told us
yet was that your impression
yes it was absolutely and he's not the
only one
uh former director of national
intelligence
john ratcliffe talked about this and
said that there was satellite imagery
of ufos and and many many more pilot
sightings that have been made public
uh we have two former cia directors
james woolsey and john brennan talking
about it
and now of course we're going to get
this report
think of it really as a proper
intelligence
assessment ufo phenomenon going from
director of national intelligence
to the senate intelligence committee
finally they are waking up and treating
this as the defense and national
security issue
those of us who've looked at it in
government have always known it to be
although if it had hostile intent uh it
would be curtains
uh wouldn't it there's not much we could
do about
uh the presumably the military power
of an extraterrestrial force which had
the
superior technology uh to be able to
visit us
at will so we might as well raise the
white flag
yes i don't think anyone's advocating
getting into a shooting war here and
of course we don't even really know for
sure that this is extraterrestrial
though interestingly it's certainly not
been
ruled out and and there's certainly my
understanding is that there's a faction
within the us government that believes
this
to be extraterrestrial but in the first
instance we need to
to find out you know for sure what we're
dealing with because these things have
been
seen in close proximity to uss
uh nimitz for example the uss princeton
so a couple of aircraft carriers several
destroyers we need to know is it our own
technology is it a foreign adversary or
is it something else
possibly even something extraterrestrial
and that's what we hope
we're going to get clarity on in the
next month or so um
do these things ever visit burundi
or or burkina faso or are they only
found
buzzing around american and british
naval assets i ask because it is quite
possible
that these are experimental weapons
either
western weapons or weapons that are
being developed by others isn't it yes
it is and that's very much one of the
theories being looked at
fairly hard here secret prototype
aircraft missiles and drones
interestingly senator marco rubio who
was acting
chair of the senate intelligence
committee said i would rather
this is extraterrestrial than say russia
or china because if that's the case the
united states has been left standing
uh but to answer your original question
we don't know
because we we don't get those reports
and that's one of the things we think
that ufos are a global
phenomenon but we really only have good
data
where we have things like satellite
coverage where we have jets flying with
ford looking infrared cameras
where we have the space tracking radar
systems at the ballistic missile early
warning centers
for example looking but it's a good
question and one we need
need more clarity on i think what uh
what kind of things are you hearing
because you're ear
is very close to the ground on these
matters
uh and you're currently i think in the
united states
uh what sort of things do you think
might be in these uh reports
well what i'm hearing is frankly they're
getting themselves into something of a
mess
over this and that there's a what you
might call a skeptic versus believer
dog fight raging at the heart of the u.s
military intelligence community
about what we're dealing with here with
factions
struggling for control of the narrative
here i
think what we are likely to get and this
report is due by late
june but i'm hearing leaks that it's
likely to be delayed
that we'll get a holding report that
that of course there are what is it
18 different parts of the us
intelligence community
the people doing this study and writing
this report
their first challenge is is to get face
time with the people
in in the know what active programs are
there in the intelligence community what
historical data
it's a big challenge they've hit some
roadblocks
so many roadblocks that the dod has
called in the office of the inspector
general
um there have been complaints about this
there have been allegations of
non-cooperation it's as i say it's a
mess now what did
president obama say i didn't see his
lips move so i've only read
reports of it what did he say that
caused
this well i think we can call it a
shockwave
well he was asked in in relation to all
these recent sightings involving the us
navy and the upcoming report to congress
what do you know and he said look
there are a lot of fairly far out rumors
circulating about
you know we've got crashed spaceships
hidden away in hangars
things being studied in laboratories he
said
he asked when he was president but
didn't
didn't get any any sort of confirmation
of that but he said
yes i am aware that we are seeing
whether it's visually from pilots or
whether it's things like
radar operators tracking them he said
we are seeing these things in our
airspace performing extraordinary speeds
and maneuvers
and accelerations and and other things
and we don't know what we're dealing
with
so he didn't go quite as far as to say
that it's
definitely extraterrestrial but my
goodness it was a
sort of heavy hint that it might be more
than just aircraft lights and weather
balloons
how hypersonic are these
uh movements that have been seen
i mean are they completely of a
different dimension
some of them are but it's it's on a
spectrum
some of the speeds are not frankly
compared to our own
that remarkable but others are and
and there have been one or two fairly
highly classified reports
suggesting things which would almost
imply a new physics
and what's what's for sure
of course is that what's been publicly
released here
is just the tip of the iceberg and the
us military intelligence community
is sitting on data some of it classified
top secret that it absolutely and
perhaps understandably is not
sharing and it's those data that would
answer your question because i think
that's where the
really um insane sounding
speeds and accelerations are
are recorded well that takes us back to
the marco rubio
point uh that if something so
hypersonic that it almost
envisages a new physics
is a weapon or a platform for a weapon
in the hands of a country other than the
united states um i expect the united
states will be praying that it's men
from mars or further beyond
yes very much so and uh former
senate majority leader harry reid
who was instrumental in setting up an
earlier pentagon
study into all this wrote to the deputy
of
defense secretary and one of the few
letters about this that has been
released into the public domain and
authenticated by the pentagon
and he talked about i'm paraphrasing but
the catastrophic
damage to the national interest of the
united states
if this technology whatever it was was
in the hands of a foreign adversary
extraordinary
now you'd did this uh for a living
you're probably still doing it for a
living but not for the mod
uh you did this in britain what were the
most
amazing things that crossed your desk
when you were in whitehall well we
received about two or three hundred
reports each year and while most of them
were misidentifications
we did have some which were quite
extraordinary and i remember a case from
where we had a wave of sightings over
the uk for a period of about six hours
huge triangular shaped craft flying
directly over
two military air bases accelerating away
at a phenomenal speed from a virtual
hover and of course
and and you'll appreciate this george or
maybe not
as the case may be we routinely told
parliament
the media and the public that these
things were a very little
defense interest but behind closed doors
some of us were seriously concerned and
that's why
i don't know if you saw i think it was
yesterday in the telegraph
a senior defense source said it's time
to reopen
these ministry of defense investigations
and he or she said we're tracking what
the us is doing now with this report
we'll keep an eye on what they say and
if we need to re-engage
on this obviously we'll do so but
absolutely we want to know what's going
on
in our airspace this is no longer a
fringe
topic or conspiracy theory it's
mainstream
defense and national security issue now
i
i don't know if you do philosophical
questions
but if you do uh let me try it
uh what does your gut tell you as a man
that's worked in this field now
for so many years decades in fact
do you think that some of this
is extraterrestrial
i'm convinced there's life out there in
the universe and i think we're very
close to defining it
through a whole range of scientific
means
whether we're being visited or not i'm
not sure i'd like to think so i guess
like fox mulder i want to believe
aliens would certainly be the most
interesting of all the potential
solutions to what we're dealing with
here and uh yeah if if that's what we're
dealing with
as we often used to say at the mod the
skeptics have to be right
every time but the believers only need
to be right once and we are in
if that's true the most game-changing
paradigm
busting uh situation imaginable and i
i hope that's what we're dealing with
and i hope
uh you know we'll get some answers on
this sooner rather than later although
of course this report going to congress
must be unclassified
but it can have a classified annex so as
ever
i'm afraid the media and the public
might not get to see the good stuff
unlike us of course so far they've come
in peace if they are they
yes i and that's my fervent hope
is that they're coming here not as
conquerors or exterminators
but as scientists as biologists
as anthropologists and uh that they're
fascinated by the biodiversity on on
this
amazing planet on which we live and
hoping
perhaps that we don't blow ourselves up
i hope they enjoyed the champions league
final
last night that would have been worth
watching even if you were in mars
thank you very much indeed nick pope as
always for joining us on the mother of
all talk shows fascinating subject this
uh give me your uh thoughts on it will
you 081
96 double five double two that's oh
eight
oh eight one nine six double five double
two
free to call me and in the us
uh plus one eight four four nine four
four three double four or tweet me
at george galloway at rt uk
news malcolm jones says on the poll
which is by the way doing uh great
business
a space is there intelligent life
in space 42
in earth on earth 25
down one and nowhere at all 33
let me have your it's a short poll this
one it will uh
close in about six minutes but malcolm
jones
says westminster is devoid
of intelligence compassion and morality
and that's a good one and martin
taylor says what do the iraqi people say
though
are they better now than under saddam
martin you've obviously been away for a
long stretch if you can even
ask that question pat branigan says
all wars are ultimately about the same
thing
land and resources they pretend all
sorts of noble causes but it just comes
down
to i want and john kamerbach
keir is doing what he was placed to do
place the red car onto its axle
stand until the blue car is losing its
torque but don't worry team neolib
will have the red team ready quite well
expressed
have i got a call give it to me then
wayne in cheshire on ufos
pleasure it's a pleasure
um i've been researching this for 30 30
plus years the phenomena
okay um we need to when you're
researching it
do you mean on the internet
mostly yeah okay you're not studied at a
university or anything like that
oh no okay because um the information
from the university wouldn't help you
anyway
all right go ahead um we need to uh
acclimatize the public uh for the
introduction of extraterrestrials
come to the conclusion at this point
that we're at
crossroads of huma human history at the
moment
we have technology to wipe out ourselves
and the earth itself but
we don't have the wisdom to control it
we need extraterrestrials to help guide
us through this
juncture if they're going to come
they are going to come soon because i
believe inevitably
we will kill ourselves either through
nuclear
biological or technical technological
means
i also believe this has happened many
times over the millennia
i was going to ask you that i mean if
they're here now
um what's to say that they haven't been
before
i i believe the earth is a nursery where
species such as ourselves
get to a techno technological point as
we are at the moment
we get helped or with all we either
survive or we don't
and then basically we leave and it
starts all over again
um the um the evidence of that is some
minds across the world are finding
similar things to mobile phones in rocks
i mean coal
that's the evidence of that that's
happened all before i've never seen any
evidence of that
when where did you see that there is
some russian coal mines
there's some evidence um but also if you
thought
if you think about it this is what we
would do if we were a space
faring community we would help other
species through their trouble at times
and like like i say if they are going to
come it's over the next number of years
because you know and i'm sure deep down
you understand
we will not make it through don't get me
wrong i believe there is an um
a god which rules the whole universe
but i also believe in extraterrestrials
and one of you that's going to have to
come to help us
you took the question literally right
out of my mouth
i don't have a problem with this as a
religious believer i believe that god is
the god of the worlds
all the worlds and this is all god's
creation
but does it pose uh moral and religious
questions
from your standpoint no it doesn't
because i've also
um studied many religions and i've come
to the conclusion
as i said before for me god is a
intelligent entity which controls the
whole universe
but the religions the religions
themselves
i've been the books example have been
rewritten so many times
they have been bastardized and used
as a controlling mechanism for humanity
now
finally uh before i go to the news have
you
ever seen any of these phenomena
i have yes tell me
um you might laugh but it's true for me
it's my truth
i have seen um energy entities
i saw two and
that that i was not getting an emotional
feeling from one of them
was love the other one was hate
one looked like a massive jellyfish
the other one looked like a massive
centipede now you laugh but that's my
truth
well you had me up to that point now i
just think you're stark raving
mad but thanks wayne in cheshire
it's time definitely a more than time
for the news with jamie lowe
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news british prime
minister boris johnson has
married his fiancee carrie simmons in
the secretly planned wedding at
westminster cathedral he's the first
prime minister to get married while in
office in nearly 200 years
the marriage took place in a small
ceremony on saturday afternoon a downing
street spokesman
said the spokesman added that the couple
would celebrate again
with family and friends next summer with
their honeymoon also delayed
until then 30 guests were invited to the
ceremony at short notice
the maximum number of attendees allowed
under covert restrictions in
england a small number of church
officials were involved in preparations
for the catholic ceremony
although johnson has been married twice
before
the roman catholic church can allow
divorcees to remarry if previous
marriages were
outside of the roman catholic church the
head of nhs providers in
england has said very very few coveted
patients in hospital have received two
coronavirus jabs showing the vaccines
provide
very high levels of protection chris
hopson said patients now tended to be
younger
meaning there was a lower need for
critical care but he said it was
incredibly striking how busy hospitals
were
as they deal with backlogs of
non-covered cases
vaccines minister nadine zahawi has
confirmed that the government is
considering making coronavirus vaccines
compulsory
for nhs staff israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu is trying to hold on
to power
by attempting to dissuade his opponents
from forming a government
centrist party leader yaya lapid has
until wednesday to build a coalition
media reports from israel say he is
close to reaching a deal with the ultra
nationalist leader nafatali binay
netanyahu israel's longest-serving prime
minister
fell short of a decisive majority at a
general election in march the fourth
in two years lapid could be close to
reaching a deal
according to analysts netanyahu who is
on trial for fraud has been in power for
12 years
and has dominated israeli politics for a
generation he was given the first chance
of forming a government
but was unable to secure the coalition
partners needed lapid's yesh
ateed party came second to netanyahu's
right-wing glacued
in the last election and was given until
june 2nd to build a coalition
president emmanuel macron has warned
that france would withdraw troops from
mali if political instability
there leads to greater islamist
radicalization it follows
a second coup in nine months in the west
african nation
macron warned of the risk of mali moving
towards greater islamist influence
france has over 5 000 troops in the
sahel region which has been a front line
in the war
against islamist militancy french troops
have been supporting forces in mali
marutiani
niger burkina and faso and chad to
battle militants
in the sahel region since 2013 macron
told the general duty march newspaper
that he had told regional leaders
that france would not support countries
where there was no democratic legitimacy
or transition and that france had no
intention of keeping troops in africa
forever
a new national flagship is to be
commissioned by the british government
in a bid to boost trade and industry
globally the prime minister has said
the vessel will be the successor to the
royal yacht britannia which was retired
in 1992
the government plans to build the ship
in the uk at a reported cost of 200
million
pounds labour said the government must
demonstrate clearly
how the ship is expected to boost trade
jobs and growth the name for the new
flagship
is yet to be announced but there is
suggestions
that it will be named after the duke of
edinburgh who helped design
britannia the vessel would be used to
promote british interests
around the world including hosting trade
fairs and diplomatic meetings
as the uk seeks to build links and boost
exports following brexit
downing street said costs for the
construction and operation of the ship
would be confirmed after the tendering
process
concluded construction is set to start
as early as next year with the ship
expected to enter the service
within the next four years at least two
people have died and more than 20 were
wounded in a shooting outside a concert
hall in florida
the shooting took place between midnight
and 1am local time in haley city
north of miami three people climbed out
of a white car
with assault rifles and handguns and
started firing indiscriminately into the
crowd police director
alfredo ramirez told reporters at least
one of the wounded is in a critical
condition police said
it comes just days after an employee at
a train yard killed nine people
on the other side of the country in
california swiss motorcycle racer jason
de pasquiere has died in hospital from
injuries sustained in a crash at the
italian grand prix
the 19 year old fell at the maguelo
circuit during
qualifying in the moto 3 class on
saturday
he was involved in a serious multi-rider
incident and was airlifted to a hospital
in florence
officials announced today that he had
died and finally
a man in washington the usa has dreamed
his whole life of finding a raw diamond
to create a one-of-a-kind engagement
ring
for his future partner but he didn't
know that it would actually become
a reality christian lydon said that the
idea of mining his own gems for an
engagement ring was planted in his head
since
school but he had no idea how to
accomplish it
later when lyden's co-worker told him
about crater of diamond state park in
arkansas
three years ago he believed his dream
could be a reality
he'd been dating his girlfriend desiree
for two years
he watched videos from those who were
successful in finding diamonds at the
park
and tried to get as much information as
he could before deciding to plan his
trip
his friend josh decided to join him
on the third day in the park after two
unsuccessful ones they decided to try a
different approach
and just mine the surface of the gravel
it was towards the end of the day
lyden said it was the last two carts and
we started
throwing materials in the screens he
said when he shook the screen there
on top was a yellow diamond weighing
over two carats
the day after lyden arrived back he and
his girlfriend went mushroom hunting
during their walk in the woods and
pulled out the diamond ring and proposed
she said yes and that's the latest here
on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
now tony gannon asks as if i would know
george are these ufos actually russian
and chinese
hypersonic drones well marco rubio hopes
not he'd rather they were coming from
mars and a long-time correspondent of
mine a very intelligent lady
by the name of diane says cummings was
telling the truth this week many of us
who'd followed the events strategies etc
that he described
we had witnessed as they happened and
knew of completely at the time
i agree with jonathan cook whose
conclusions on cummings answering
in front of the parliamentary committee
were identical to mine
he said that cummings is trying to
replace the inefficient corrupt
johnson and hancock with the more
efficient
and corrupt gov and sunak
the kind of systems global and corporate
capitalism
that cummings espouses as do sunak and
gov
is not nice it's the ultimate in
neoliberal
backed by neocon war this was
actually obvious to see for those that
would in cummings lengthy submission
last week
cummings may genuinely have some regret
for his part in wantonly cavalierly
and fully consciously causing thousands
of unnecessary
british deaths but it looks as though he
johnson hancock and sunak gov
and the rest will get away with it for
now
both sunak and gov are in cabinet
and did nothing to stop johnson and
hancock strategies
or the lack of them much
else in that email but too long to read
out
someone sent me a picture of a
hundred-year-old iphone in the grave of
a woman buried
in a russian atlantis it didn't convince
me
i've got to say now
lee cronin is not just the professor of
chemistry at the university of glasgow
he's working on a new tool to help
humans
find alien life in the
universe he is the regis professor
as i say and his team have come up with
the assembly theory
which is a new way of quantifying
molecular complexity
which can be used to determine if a
molecule required
a biological system to create it
or if it happened by chance
they're working with nasa to make
new life detection instruments which
could be sent on missions
into space to trace alien life
now he thinks that there is
life on mars but that it will be boring
amazing he joins me now professor
lee cronin professor of chemistry at the
university of
glasgow that was a bit of a letdown the
good news is there's life
on mars the bad news is it's boring
what do you mean professor hi good
evening pleasure to be with you
okay so i i mars is very close to earth
and it would seem that probably the
mars was very similar to earth when it
was um
when it was a different place it was
more what we call habitable
so i was kind of making a flip comment
of course we could find life on
mars any life or evidence in life it
would be amazing
the first question is is is there life
on mars and if the life
we find on mars is similar to life we
find on earth like made up of dna
and proteins and the same chemistry we
find and
uh then that will be what i mean by
boring but not really
it will be amazing it will be amazing uh
but i get your point
uh but but your detection system
can find life that
didn't require biology to create it what
do you mean by that dichotomy
so what i mean is so if we go to mars
and we try and just look for earth-like
light if we don't find earth-like light
then we we might miss
our life what our approach does is to
say well look
let's not go with any idea of what the
life looks like
um so like biology on earth let's try
and work out if we can be as
open-minded as possible for alien
biology and so what our technique will
do will allow you to find not only earth
life
but any life um no matter what the
chemistry because it only looks for the
evidence of complexity
and so that that's how we built the
technique and we verified the technique
in the laboratory over the past few
years
and uh we're getting ready to kind of go
further afield
well that's great news for the
university of glasgow that i
represented for quite a long time in
parliament i'm very glad to
hear that who are the customers for this
nasa
anyone else you're making available to
other
space faring china russia
so i think at the moment i think um the
only uh
so it's it's just published in open
access journal so anyone can
look at it i'm working with nasa they
helped
develop that approach with me and
the nice thing for is it the customer
isn't just looking for
isn't just going to be space
faring nations actually this approach
can be used to discover new drugs as
well as a laboratory
and also make new life forms so we're
using this approach in the lab
practically to fact say
search for new antibiotics and new drugs
i i could explain why it makes a bit
weird but it actually works quite nicely
and we're going to go elsewhere and i
think the where i really want to go is
the
outer solar system or to somewhere
really quite strange like venus
um to look for weird life in in
in around us i'm uh i'm an
interested uh layman
amateur uh in this but it seems to me uh
a decently workable thesis uh that
mars was once a planet uh
perhaps quite like ours uh but that it
died
uh a melancholy inference from that is
that that's what will happen to
us am i widely off the mark there
no not really we just don't so mars was
a bit smaller so
mars wasn't able to hang on for its
atmosphere for as long and so because
mars was smaller
and um it didn't have a magnetic field
the magnetic so what happens on earth
we've got some magnetic field that keeps
our atmosphere
with us so that's why earth has survived
longer so there's lots of reasons to
expect and hope that
the the earth will go for much longer
than mars it already has
but what's really exciting is mars was
habitable before earth
so probably the chemistry for life on
earth got cooking
on mars almost like the aperitif for
life on earth could have started on mars
and actually but got sent to earth on a
meteorite
and in fact we're all martians and by
one of the reasons why go into mars to
have a look is we found a new type of
life form
that's different to life on earth but
related we might find that we are
actually the great grandchildren of life
on mars
but don't worry we might survive longer
because we can keep our atmosphere for
longer
as long as we don't screw things up
through global warming and nuclear
disaster and other things like that
indeed so uh the sociology
lags behind your brilliant technology
that's for sure
um i'm i'm fascinated by your wish to go
farther uh it'll cost
take a very long time to go to venus
uh how realistic is it that uh
craft can i mean can you land on venus
yes so actually venus is a lot closer
these venus is the cheapest one the
cheapest places to get to
but is it to land there now i'm not
entirely
sure if my memory serves me correctly
but i believe that the right
the russians landed two vehicles on on
venus
um um in the about 30 or 40 years ago
so it is possible to land there but they
don't survive for very long
i think the u.s has already also been
there so going to venus will be one
option
but what's really exciting is to go to
other places in the solar system where
there is
water and carbon like on earth and one
such
place is a europa and there's another
place where i think it's interesting
they're called titan
and and actually in a few years nasa is
going to send a nuclear-powered drone
to titan that has a special nose on it
and the nose that it has
will you be able to use my technique so
we might within the next 10 years be
able to find weird life
on titan using this nuclear-powered
drone with this with this special nose
and of course you're talking about our
solar system
there are very many solar systems
uh could there be more than one universe
well um i think so let's i think there
could be more than one so many
more than one habitable solar system in
the universe in our universe
i'm not sure about depends how you
define the universe but to kind of
um say one thing extra the technique
we've approached
is very good if you can go and collect
the molecules
but we have developed a new technique
where you can basically use
a telescope to look for complex
molecules
from very long distances so we might be
even able to find complex molecules
in other solar systems in our current
universe um in the next
next 20 or 30 years by extending this
technique
because it works in the thing called the
infrared were um
very well so i'm super excited about
that i'm pretty sure we will find life
if it's out there
we just have to go we just have to be
really open-minded when we go and look
well i had nick pope the mod
uh specialist in ufos it could be that
whilst we are so far vainly trying to
find them
they've already found us does your
thought process intersect with that
point in any way
um so yeah i mean um yes and no i
there is life elsewhere in the universe
is there any evidence that
ufos are visiting earth right now not
really
there are anomalies that people are
excited about
but i think actually the ufo phenomena
um
it's a bit i think we should pay
attention to not because there are
ufos visiting us but how people will
react when they find that when we find
life elsewhere in the universe
culturally this is going to be really
powerful and i think
maybe the reason why people want to
believe in ufos is
this this this wish to know are we alone
in the universe
what are we doing here what is life all
about and what what is the future for
life on earth
so i don't want to ridicule those people
who believe in ufos but it is a belief
there is no evidence
well i i don't know if you're aware
because you're obviously
deeply immersed in your own work but
president obama made some comments uh
recently
and there is a report going to congress
at the end of june
which will apparently reveal
either the existence of phenomena
mind bending in its uh
sophistication uh marco rubio the
senator is hoping that it's
extraterrestrial
because if it isn't it means that russia
and china have got some
a pretty spectacular kit uh out there uh
it is becoming a bit more mainstream
professor
no no so i'll tell you what's going on
i'm aware of all this work
very well the u.s navy and the pentagon
want a little bit of
publicity for funding okay the
anomalies we have seen are advanced
image
anomalies that can be explained with a
little bit of critical thinking
looking at flaring on the surface of the
ccd
believe me i'm the first to be there and
want to find aliens
just think critically for a second if
aliens have advanced technology
and they're able to fly to us why have
we not seen any more information why is
it just the us navy
let's think a bit more why is it the
quality of the photographs and the
information we're seeing not improving
and so i think what obama is going to
say and the pentagon says there are
really
interesting anomalies we're picking up
um with our equipment right now
let's have a look and update it that is
not the same thing as saying they're
ufos
i think my i try to be as humble as
possible about this about the
possibility of course aliens could be
visiting us
have we seen any compelling evidence no
um
but that doesn't mean that the u.s state
department the pentagon
and so on are not going to release some
very interesting information
but i i wouldn't necessarily have a
wager with you but i'm pretty sure that
it's going to be very
exciting to look at the anomalies but
they are nevertheless
um anomalies in uh
uh in our atmosphere and and whether and
russia and china do have sophisticated
tech so to the us so do other places
but you know um i'm also going to be
very interested
to see what is this declassified because
they've really pumped us all up haven't
they
well they pump me up let up let's uh
talk again perhaps
after the report comes out and the very
best of luck with your
i was going to say groundbreaking work
but it's far more
than that it is cosmically important
professor proud of you lee cronin
professor
of chemistry at the university of
glasgow thanks for joining us
on the mother of all talk shows now uh
here's poll
number two for carrie simon's marriage
to
boris johnson is it a congratulations
b she got lucky or c
a whitewash a means of burying bad news
you can
of course vote uh on
that now apparently i've got
a question that i can ask you but i have
misplaced it so you'll have to wait
on the 2nd of june
1953 people crowded around
this new fancy device called television
to watch what now that's 1953
right that's just a year
and a month before i was born and i'm
not methuselah
on the 2nd of june in 1953 people
crowded round this new device called
television to watch what a the queen's
coronation
be the cup final or c
valdenke could be
could be val now on dominic cummings
frank hayes says george it's easy to get
rid of kia
but who would replace them momentum and
centrist playwrights cannot and will
never be
reconciled well maybe the labour party
will divide maybe it should
divide but what britain can't afford
frank is to have no opposition
on this whole covered thing for example
a kierstarmer has tail ended boris
johnson
every step of the way that's why he
cannot exploit
the failing self-evident failings
of the prime minister and his cabinet
because
he supported them every step
of the way kierstarmer believes in
nothing
and nobody believes in kier starmer
john camerbach is back dominic cummings
is spreading the blame
he's defusing the situation cummings
knows the tricks and knows
he's still part of the team not so sure
about that
i'll take more of your calls after the
break
radio sputnik
[Music]
call me come and have a go if you think
you're hard enough
don't bring up a false name come on air
call me and let's have this mata out
[Music]
let's get ready to run
[Applause]
how have you know enough to tell people
to plex it
if you have not if you're not telling
them
that's 2016's argument michael i'm no
longer
arguing with you about the merits of
brexit
i'm arguing with you about democracy
about the right of the majority
to have their decision their vote
implemented
[Music]
not have a referendum and let them sort
out among themselves i want
a referendum let me put that in capital
letters if you think
this year which is shaping up already to
be an
honest miserables for the snp if you
think this is your year
go ahead come on let's have it out
but no george it's not as simple as that
right have you seen the documentary
about camera analytica and people who
work there
have you looked at this i know nothing
about that i'm not interested in this
precisely
i'm not interested in them bruce because
it's all a red herring
just like russia gay was a red herring
do you only want to hear voices that
agree
with you because if you do you're not
clever enough to be at this
open university of the airwaves in fact
you need to go back to remedial
and learn something about what democracy
and freedom of speech actually mean
[Music]
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
well it could have been valdonicum that
everyone crowded around their
tv sets in june of 1953
to watch i'm sure val was in his
lovely woolly jumpers still troubadoring
in those days uh god uh
god rest his soul valdurnican it could
have been the cup final but it wouldn't
have been as great a cup final as i've
watched
last night between chelsea and
manchester city
big congratulations to chelsea on
a great and well-deserved victory but it
was
in fact the queen's coronation
let's take a call tariff in new orleans
what have you got to say tariff
thank you for taking my call i want to
um bring up something that met you
edward
said which i don't know i know people
don't know who he is he's a journalist
for canadianpatrickpress.com
he did research using norm normy klein
journalist research and other research
they had these documents that was
declassified by the cia
i mean from the government dealing with
the cia documents yet this man named
sir henry pizzer was part of he was the
chief advisor
scientific advisor for the um the
british military
chief of british military um the
military
defense he was part of that he was um
specializing in retail technology and
whatnot he was part of it
he made the first ufo
group in 1950 pre-project
blue book that came out 1952 and also
in 1951 he went to a meeting in um
montreal come back corbett the rich
culture hotel where he met with um
a um almond almonds sullivan in
defense research of uh development of
canada he was part of that that guy
and also representatives of the cia to
discuss brainwashing
okay that was in 1951 by 1953
the cia developed mk ultra okay
so when you look back at night in the
1930s they had a psychiatry had a
psychiatric
um they had a program ran in 1930s
called attack of the worlds i forgot the
man at broadcaster
where he had people lost their mind was
shooting at water towers
and some people died because of it from
that and also
dealing with the military being involved
with um ufo research then
later on came mk ultra they might have a
tie between ufo
um fails to study in mk ultra
okay i also want to say it's four things
going on right now
you have the us government might have
some type of
technology that might be good but not
great
electronic jamming of um radio systems
to make it appear that aircraft is going
very fast
cgi dealing with um manipulation of
camera
footage and the last thing dealing with
propaganda making it
right all of these are possibilities and
professor lee cronin
a very clever man i think it's all uh
a means by which uh the various
departments can leverage
even more money out of the u.s taxpayer
so for example
you could say these extraordinary
maneuverability and speeds
uh if they are belonging to
uh hostile or at least adversaries of
the united states
we better catch up so you better spend a
few
extra trillions on our technology
it could be just like jack kennedy
inherited
the so-called missile gap which
never existed but which kennedy was
told existed and then committed himself
to vast increases in military
expenditure in the us
to close a missile gap with the soviet
union that didn't
actually exist terry thanks for the call
let's uh stay on your continent go to
sao paulo in brazil where samuel awaits
samuel welcome uh hi george
thanks for having me welcome uh uh i'd
like
to to start just agreeing with what you
just said i think
this ufo thing now regardless of the
intention
uh can have only two consequences
distract us from this crisis that we
live in now that's the
biggest transfer of wealth to ever
fewer hands and to funnel more
resources especially the military
justified by this
ufo thing which in the end gets
more money to the same hands i think
instead of looking to the sky
now especially from a socialist point of
view i think it's time for us to reach
out to
each other to the working class
physically
reach out to each other and start
determine that the the tone
of the dialogue about people
instead of just commenting on what biden
said about putin or what cg being
identifying every of these
leaders with their people i think so the
world american working class the british
working class the cuban working class
uh the russian working class the iranian
working for the palestinian working
class start
reach out to each other and establish
and create the
uh even eventually say this peace
treaties
and commitments because the working
class is the only
actor almost capable of stopping
every single wall the working class is
the one who builds the bombs the one who
received the
in their heads okay i think i've got you
uh not everyone is a socialist of course
uh and it's possible that you can have
your feet in the gutter and your
eyes looking up at the stars to
paraphrase
the great oscar wilde it's possible that
you can do
both i'm in favor of space
exploration and i'm in favor
of inoculating the world against malaria
and wiping
out which we can do for a mere fraction
of what we spend on armaments it's
possible that we can
chew gum and walk at the same time
besides uh the the development of
science as
the professor cronin just pointed out
that is
applicable in space can also
make new antibiotics here
on earth and cure
sickness and disease here uh so thank
you let him
restart it yeah okay that's what do you
got
so let's of course i'm in fact i'm
infectious disease specialist i'm not
against any research
just saying that this team is
from a social point of view from an
anti-war point of view i think
works more as a distraction than any
any other thing and it's more justifying
the more expenditure in this thing just
like this
10 billion bailout the u.s senate is
about to give to
jeff bezos basically covering his
9 billion dollars he used to buy
warner brothers so i think most
if we can look everywhere but if we
don't start
looking to each other we our even our
idea of
our expectations as uh the human
gender is getting poorer and poorer and
mediocre by the day
okay uh i forgot to cut your shorts
samuels a lot of people
want to talk but thanks for the call
let's stay there
and go to florida where elliot is on the
line
elliot welcome
oh george yeah hi go ahead
uh thank you george uh so good to talk
to you again
you know as the last caller just took
away my thunder i i totally agree
with uh what he said uh in most parts
but uh my
main point was my main knee-jerk
reaction when the report
in the united states uh uh you know from
the government and from
securities uh surfaced uh you know it
was that it was a psyops
operation because we're so used to in
this country on the left we're so used
to
psyop operations and the media kindly
distracting you with
one thing or another and it seemed
perfectly made for that
but on another level uh it it just seems
the pictures that you that are being
projected
as the these objects are always the same
that
this is that for 50 years there are
always these grainy
hard to hard to see objects
and uh i'm just very skeptical of yeah
you're right i mean the flying saucer
hasn't developed much over the course of
my lifetime
it looks exactly the same as it did when
i was a kid
uh i'm more interested in the speed
uh of uh and maneuverability from a
standing start uh rather than the
pictures i'm interested more in the
in the radar in the uh
the testimony of the pilots
about what they saw in terms of
the super human speed supersonic
hypersonic speed from a standing start
of for example
these triangular shaped objects that
that nick pope was talking about earlier
i've not remotely persuaded that a giant
centipede
uh is uh seeking to uh
seeking to show love or aggression
towards you i never got a chance to ask
him
uh you could probably get along with
loving uh a giant jellyfish but
a big centipede coming after you might
be quite frightening
well you know i'm a bit ambivalent
on the issue on some level because i
have seen
uh and been with friends and we have
seen large triangular
light uh objects flying uh overhead at a
very low speed or i have
close friends in my life that have
pulled me back back in the late 60s and
early 70s
they actually saw the softer land in
front of them or passed by in new york
or go overhead
i've never but you know i don't know how
to react to that
um i'm still a skeptic that there is any
uh
life that uh and another planet that can
come and visit
but yet um these things are there
and i understand it would be the
government
it would be quite unlikely that uh of
all the
billions hundreds or billions of planets
uh that exist that there was only ever
life on one of them wouldn't it well i
believe it though
i believe we we are it even though
i do believe in the mystical sense the
entire universe is conscious
and alive and that consciousness goes
throughout all of us
and through everything in a mystical way
i don't believe that there are actually
other planets too many and i
say that because after so many decades
of looking for
this life there there really hasn't been
any boundaries oh but that's a mere
second in historical time but thanks uh
elliot pat is in south carolina
he's seen a ufo we better talk to him
pat south carolina welcome go ahead
hi george it's pat and i am a girl i'm
female
oh yeah i thought yeah
yes i saw yepo in the 1970s middle
1970s and i was living in meridian
mississippi at the time
uh i got a phone call i was in the house
somebody said go
up told me to go look in the sky so i
went outside and it was just
before dark i went out there and there
was this
massive and when i say massive the
person who called me was
miles away from me and it appeared as
big to them
as it did to me and i'm looking at it
and and it looked like it was just
spinning right above
you know above the trees but i couldn't
tell how high above the trees it was so
big it was just it seemed like it was
a tree what shape was it
well the thing about it it was
iridescent as if it were spinning
so fast that but there was a light there
were light it
there was a light created it was like an
iridescent
light and it was you couldn't see a
solid form it was just an iridescent
light
but george we're looking at it cars are
stopped
people are getting out of their cars
there are people who saw this other than
me
okay they were all standing there my
children were with me were looking up at
this
and then all of a sudden see the naval
air station
is in meridian meridian naval air
station
and these two jets go flying by uh
towards each other nose to you know
toward heading towards each other
and this was in i guess what you'd say
maybe
heading towards this thing that we were
looking at and
we're still looking at because we're
mesmerized in it right in front of my
eyes i'm telling you george this is not
an exaggeration
as fast as you can blink or or through
two to three seconds or maybe that was
too long
it went in front of my eyes up
and turned into a what like a star way
up in the sky it was it looked exactly
like a star
kind of glittering a little but but not
as
not as so it disappeared different than
a star it had a dullness
it disappeared from your view
upwards and extraordinarily quickly
yeah i'm i'm so fast i mean it was like
as fast as you can blink almost as those
jets were heading
right to it and it was gone
it was gone it was not in the paper the
next day
it was not in the news on the news
report at night
it was not on the radio and my husband
at the time was working at the radio
station
nothing there was nothing not a word
and not too long before that and i only
remember this
because of the coincidence there were
two men
who lived in pascagoula or they were
fishing i don't know if they lived there
i just know they were fishing and
claimed they had been taken aboard an
air
a spaceship right and had been analyzed
or studied or whatever that i don't
remember the details because i wasn't
paying a lot of attention at the time
but everybody thought this is cuckoo but
the quad the story was continuing
and then it just suddenly just uh
dropped and i've often wondered
what you know what happened with that
story but it wasn't that long
before what we saw that day
and i'm telling you there were people
there
in the street with me cars stopped
looking there are people who know they
saw what i saw
and miles away so i don't know how many
other people might have seen it
you know i got a phone call from someone
miles away go look up in the sky
and and i talked with them afterwards
and it appeared
as large to them where they were
i'm talking about miles away when i say
miles i mean
15 20. uh yeah it appeared as large to
them as it did to us
well that is fascinating thank you uh
very much
for the eyewitness uh testimony
and i've got to take a break uh
unfortunately
operation dynamo took place on the 4th
of june
in 1940 was it a
the splitting of the atom b
the dunkirk evacuation see
the cracking of the enigma code
i'll give you the answer along with more
calls
after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
you know and it's a very thank you for
you know i'm a big fan of your show gg
great great debate great and i'm
scottish i'm very passionate about
what's happening there you know
i had a great mom she was scottish mary
mcleod
she taught me well she taught me well at
everything including golf
i love scotland and i love the scottish
food
it's great food i said to melania you
know haggis look at that
much more than more scottish than that
me
i am that haggis she said what thin
skinned and full of crap
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik telling the untold
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
the 4th of june 1940
was the dunkirk evacuation
uh defeat which mr churchill turned into
a victory now on barris
and uh boris and carrie
marco polo says i wish them the best
in a year boris has been critically ill
dealt with a pandemic
partner has a baby now married that's
some roller coaster
he deserves a break in my viewpoint and
matt says completely agree politicians
are people
usually trying to do their best whatever
their politics
two people getting married should always
be a time
for congratulations
and uh borg
says dominic cummings is only upset
because he wasn't invited
to boris's wedding and on the ufos
uh we're being snowed under by then
we're under alien attack
multi clapton says how many starving
people could you save with the budget of
space
travel except that would not be what
they would do with the money being spent
on space travel because i don't run the
world
multi clapton and neither do you
alan harris says obama won't call them
aliens
just undocumented life forms and
malice says how can anyone be an expert
on things that are
unexplained if your expert can explain
the unexplained
then it's no longer unexplained and
andrew wales says am i missing something
or hasn't george backed lockdowns
what are you talking about and
tony in liverpool says anyone who went
to the grafton
in liverpool would see extraterrestrials
every friday and saturday night and uh
anthony says i'm so disillusioned
i'm hoping that quite soon man can land
on the sun
tim wilson says quite tautological to
paul
if there's no intelligence anywhere
whilst posing the question
very parliamentary well
i'm not responsible for that tautology
or any of the polls
any of their wording or any of their
subjects
but it is an interesting philosophical
question
that you pose perhaps someone will
call in to uh contribute
ross says they're treating us like
idiots there are no
alien intelligences visiting earth the
us elite is up to something
as always and martin taylor says
ufos are thought to originate from a lab
in and on labor dr max
davison says uh we have a better society
now
for the disabled and uh max says
kyo starmer should sell sandals he's an
expert in flip flopping
and uh stuart wheeler says dominic
cunnings handed the labour party
the smoking gun they needed to bring
down boris johnson
john ashworth and keith starmer threw
that smoking gun
straight into a bucket of water lest it
damage him
they are barely even going through the
motions
of being an opposition that's the tweet
of the night
so far stewart let's go to
gerasimos in ottawa in canada
gerasimos welcome to the show
thank you sir
how good to talk to you thank you nice
to hear from you
i have a little story i want to share
with you go on
well it happened quite a while ago in
58 i was just a 12 year old with my
brother
and he called me to look out of the
window and we looked up in the sky
and there was
a cigar-shaped object moving very
rapidly
from north to south we got my telescope
i just received the telescope for my
12th birthday and we watched this thing
and we watched it for six and a half
minutes
uh again there was some fluff in the
newspapers the next day
but nothing more was said that was the
one
brother it couldn't have been moving
very rapidly if you were able to watch
it for
six and a half minutes if i was going
from horizon to horizon
up and down left and right over and up
so it was in every direction
crisscrossing i've got here
crisscrossing in front of us now when
you see a cigar-shaped i'm familiar with
cigars i used to smoke them
uh was it uh was it one of
my monte cristo number twos was it
fatter at one end than the other or was
it
uh yeah was it the same shape the whole
night
it was a nice monte cristo number two
tapered cigar
on one side then in the center of it
there was a red
part of the of the the whole ship
uh and we heard no noise uh
so it was silent now you and your
brother
saw it does your brother remember
exactly as you do
identically and do you think anyone else
saw it well we know that other people
saw it because it was in the newspaper
the next day
okay but it was uh tossed off as being a
weather balloon
but weather balloons don't go crisscross
across the sky
in in that kind of uh pattern
there have been weather balloons uh
mistakenly
identified as ufos but you're
you're convinced this one wasn't
no i'm pretty sure and and then in 1974
i was walking
outside of saint catherine's monastery
with the archbishops of sinai
then archbishop damianos and we looked
up to the sky
and we saw a silver light which
moved rapidly from one place to another
much faster than any airplane so that
was both of us saw that
the archbishop saw it too
he did and he's the one who pointed it
out to me
did he think about it do you think a
godly
sign he thought it was
a very unusual thing to see his exact
words
very much unusual sight very interesting
thanks for the call
different subject now boris johnson
terence and norwich
go ahead terence hello mr galloway nice
to speak to you and you sir um
earlier on i found it remarkably i
enjoyed mrs stanton talking about
body language etc but for me you go back
to the first year of all the generals
send it the upper class who sent the
kids to war a glorious glorious way to
go
until they realized that they kids they
wanted to keep them second world war
they didn't send so many or they made
them captains they watched the
proletariat day
come in johnson at all they don't care a
flay
a fig about deaths in britain they
vastly underestimate everything they
wouldn't listen to science
but i'm not surprised by cummins or
johnson it's like rats in the sack
uh pretty pretty pathetic i like you why
do you think they've fallen out
then terence well i think it's a
question of
of incompetence wanting to be the more
incompetent i mean you cannot
in one instance drive and pretend you uh
flagler v
flagrantly disregarding lockdown when
he's going up to obviously he's tested
wear a beanie hat and try to look 29 to
appeal to a demographic
when he's gone for 60 years of age
cummings uh a serial philanderer they
fell out simply because of power
and this is the upper classes just to be
clear
dominic cummings is not a serial
philanderer
you were referring to
boris johnson that's right well of
course and he is a serious
guy he definitely can't sue us for that
no no i ain't well he could try to sue
me i wouldn't care less i mean
having i've had issues with the child
support agency i've mentioned him in
many
many letters because i'm not ashamed to
say i'm the father of my daughters
leaving the other side i'll come back to
my point mr galloway
go on my point is this mr galloway that
the both of them are in the same sack
that's the leftovers of any leading uh
strata of society and that's all we've
got hancock's half-hour
you've got pretty pathetic should have
been sacked they're
they're in the same sack they just want
power they're incompetent and they don't
care about your grandmothers
who've died your uncles who died and
they still don't care mr galloway
as far as i'm concerned as far as i'm
concerned too i i think they should all
be on trial
for corporate manslaughter yes
and that's why when you were a member of
the parliament
uh you were very very much disliked but
your people have voted for you likely to
vote you in all the time
um because you you sometimes uh were not
afraid of telling the truth
which is what i'm all about saint
augustine it will always be the truth
and these people
that are running britain have lied
systematically
richie t snack eat out to kill out it's
it's dreadful you're good you need to
write some lines for me terence
thank you very much indeed for that
excellent call
have i got time for cornelius in swansea
yes
cornelius go ahead how are you yes um
regarding comments um um i honestly
think that um
well the people first of all that are
calling out cummins at the moment
and and blaming the government that they
never lock down sooner
are the same people that were saying
that uh president trump was a racist
because he locked down his country and
stopped flights coming in from china
stop flights coming from europe
two days later he stopped flights going
coming from the uk
why didn't we lock down our airports
we're an island
we could have uh much more easily than
many other countries
stopped people coming in here
yeah for sure i mean i mean obviously i
i agree with that totally that
there has been mistakes made by the
government but i mean it's easy in
hindsight and it's easy sitting on the
fence and it's easy to criticize
okay it's not hindsight in my case i was
saying it here
uh as the crisis unfolded from the first
day
uh so and dr ranjit
uh the moats medic were saying it every
single week
so it's not there's no hindsight
involved and nobody pays
us cornelius but the people we do
pay made an absolute cod of it
well well yes yes yes and no
i mean i mean um the the situation in
care homes
um obviously that was a disaster and the
nightingale hospitals that they opened
up they never use
i mean people that were put back in care
homes from hospitals should have been
put in those nightingale hospitals make
sure
they're okay that's a pretty big guy you
know i mean
i think i'm reading you that you are in
general a defender
of the government's uh stance no no no
no no no i'm not saying i'm a a defender
of the government i have got no
allegiance to any party whatsoever
but i just think yeah but what you just
said there and i agree with it
that is the corporate manslaughter
of thousands of our old people doesn't
get much worse than that
yeah sure but did you hear anybody
calling up to you george and
condemning china up not shutting their
borders they knew they had that highly
contagious
they knew hang on a minute they knew
they had a highly contagious virus on
the loose
and they did not shut the borders well
the real fools are those that allowed
chinese
flights to land in their country
not china do you think they are the
fools not china
no of course if people wanted
out of china uh and china had stopped
them from
leaving uh we would have been in the
middle of a scandal of
a big chinese kidnap uh the fools are
those that allowed
every day flights to come from china
from new york from new delhi
new delhi with the indian variant was
still
flying people into britain several times
a day
last week it's us that's the fools
dang on i want it george hang a minute
everybody in the media they're jumping
on a bandwagon regardless indian variant
okay the indian variant is maybe more
contagious
but it's not that no no serious than any
of the pa or any of the common vitals
we've had this year
okay the majority of the people in the
united kingdom have been vaccinated
the vulnerable has been vaccinated if
people
that are that are vulnerable ethnic
communities whoever
that are not prepared to take the
vaccine well if they get serious
actually most of the people who are
refusing to take the vaccine
have nothing to do with the ethnic
community your mask
slipped there if you look at the mass
demonstrations all over this country
against
vaccination covid is a hoax and so on
they're overwhelmingly white british
people
yes george i know that but then but you
listen to the labor party and you listen
to
lavi or whatever his name is he keeps
bringing up the thing about
diversity they keep bringing up about
regarding ethnic communities
don't class me with that david lammy uh
cornelius thanks the time is uh
such that i can't uh continue our
interesting conversation because in a
few seconds
i have to go uh to the news with jimmy
love but i wanted to
tell you that after the break
after the news we've got the sage
that is caleb mopa talking about united
states politics and media
and our very own and utterly
irrepressible
patrick christie's let me give you
a question to go out with
whose album featuring creatures from
outer space
was released in this week in 1972
a led zeppelin b david bowie
c adam and the ants let's go to the news
with jamie law
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news british prime
minister boris johnson has married his
fiancee carrie simmons
in the secretly planned wedding at
westminster cathedral he's the first
prime minister to get married
while in office in nearly 200 years the
marriage took place in a small ceremony
on saturday afternoon a downing street
spokesman said
the spokesman added that the couple
would celebrate again
with family and friends next summer with
their honeymoon also delayed
until then 30 guests were invited to the
ceremony at short notice the maximum
number of attendees allowed undercovered
restrictions in england
a small number of church officials were
involved in preparations for the
catholic ceremony
although johnson has been married twice
before
the roman catholic church can allow
divorcees to remarry if previous
marriages were
outside of the roman catholic church the
head of
nhs providers in england has said very
very few coveted patients in hospital
have received two coronavirus jabs
showing the vaccines provide very high
levels of protection
chris hopson said patients now tended to
be younger
meaning there was a lower need for
critical care but he said
it was incredibly striking how busy
hospitals were
as they deal with backlogs of non-covert
cases
vaccines minister nadine zahawi has
confirmed that the government is
considering making coronavirus vaccines
compulsory
for nhs staff israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu is trying to hold on
to power
by attempting to dissuade his opponents
from forming a government
centrist party leader yaya lapid has
until wednesday to build a coalition
media reports from israel say he is
close to reaching a deal with the ultra
nationalist leader nafatali binay
netanyahu israel's longest-serving prime
minister
fell short of a decisive majority at a
general election in march the fourth
in two years lapid could be close to
reaching a deal
according to analysts netanyahu who is
on trial for fraud has been in power for
12 years
and has dominated israeli politics for a
generation he was given the first chance
of forming a government
but was unable to secure the coalition
partners needed lapid's yesh
ateed party came second to netanyahu's
right-wing glacued
in the last election and was given until
june 2nd to build a coalition
president emmanuel macron has warned
that france would withdraw troops from
mali if political instability there
leads to greater islamists
radicalization
it follows a second coup in nine months
in the west african nation
macron warned of the risk of mali moving
towards greater islamist influence
france has over 5 000 troops in the
sahel region which has been a front line
in the war
against islamist militancy french troops
have been supporting forces in mali
marutiani
niger burkina and faso and chad to
battle militants
in the sahel region since 2013 macron
told the general duty march newspaper
that he had told regional leaders
that france would not support countries
where there was no democratic legitimacy
or transition and that france had no
intention of keeping troops in africa
forever
a new national flagship is to be
commissioned by the british government
in a bid to boost trade and industry
globally the prime minister has said
the vessel will be the successor to the
royal yacht britannia which was retired
in 1997.
the government plans to build the ship
in the uk at a reported cost of 200
million
pounds labour said the government must
demonstrate clearly
how the ship is expected to boost trade
jobs and growth
the name for the new flagship is yet to
be announced
but there is suggestions that it will be
named after the duke of edinburgh who
helped design
britannia the vessel would be used to
promote british interests
around the world including hosting trade
fairs and diplomatic meetings
as the uk seeks to build links and boost
exports following brexit
downing street said costs for the
construction and operation of the ship
would be confirmed after the tendering
process
concluded construction is set to start
as early as next year with the ship
expected to enter the service
within the next four years at least two
people have died and more than 20 were
wounded in a shooting outside a concert
hall in florida
the shooting took place between midnight
and 1am local time in haley city
north of miami three people climbed out
of a white car
with assault rifles and handguns and
started firing indiscriminately into the
crowd police director
alfredo ramirez told reporters at least
one of the wounded is in a critical
condition police said it comes just days
after an employee at a train yard killed
nine people on the other side of the
country in california swiss motorcycle
racer jason de pasquiere has died in
hospital from
injuries sustained in a crash at the
italian grand prix
the nineteen-year-old fell at the
maguelo circuit during
qualifying in the moto 3 class on
saturday
he was involved in a serious multi-rider
incident
and was airlifted to a hospital in
florence officials
announced today that he had died and
finally a man in washington the usa has
dreamed his whole life of finding a raw
diamond to create a one-of-a-kind
engagement ring for his future partner
but he didn't know that it would
actually become a reality
christian lydon said that the idea of
mining his own gems for an engagement
ring was planted in his head
since school but he had no idea how to
accomplish it
later when lyden's co-worker told him
about crater of diamond state park in
arkansas three years ago he believed his
dream could be a reality
he'd been dating his girlfriend desiree
for two years
he watched videos from those who were
successful in finding diamonds at the
park
and tried to get as much information as
he could before deciding to plan his
trip
his friend josh decided to join him
on the third day in the park after two
unsuccessful ones they decided to try a
different approach
and just mine the surface of the gravel
it was towards the end of the day
lyden said it was the last two carts and
we started
throwing materials in the screens he
said when he shook the screen there on
top was a yellow diamond
weighing over two carats the day after
lyden arrived back he and his girlfriend
went mushroom hunting
during their walk in the woods and
pulled out the diamond ring and proposed
she said yes and that's the latest here
on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
now whose album featuring creatures from
outer space
was released in this week in 1972
a led zeppelin b david boy or c
adam and the ants these three names take
me back
well of course it was david boy
now uh the poll will close in about 25
minutes
so half past is the end of this poll
plenty of people voting and uh i'm glad
to say
actually the great majority of you uh
say that the
marriage of mr and mrs boris johnson is
a cause for
congratulations 61 up to
b she got lucky seven percent
down one who of the seven percent that
think carrie simons is the lucky one
in that marriage and see whitewash
i.e cover-up to distract
32 of course the bans must have been
posted
some weeks ago he could not necessarily
have planned it for this weekend knowing
what was going to happen in the last
week but hey
people like to believe these things
so 32 percent of you think it's a
whitewash
down one so you've got still
20 minutes that you can cast your vote
now
my colleague on rt america
caleb mopan is one of the smartest
political operators
on the continent and i wanted to
talk to him tonight about u.s media
and u.s politics and i'm glad to say he
agreed uh caleb thank you for joining us
as uh always let's start with uh
your president uh where is he at the
moment
does he know he's there and what is he
up to
indeed people are looking at joe biden
and especially as he seems to get a
little tired in the summer heat and
wondering exactly what's going on he's
got an infrastructure plan
that is subject to constant negotiation
there does not seem to be
even a clear consensus within his own
party about what it will
and will not include a lot of chaos uh
we've got the
vice president kamala harris uh making
some woke
jokes before u.s navy graduates that
aren't exactly going over and many
criticizing her tweets around memorial
day
uh this is a situation where the country
is still
in ruins following the pandemic we've
got infrastructure falling apart that
was a problem
long before the pandemic came along joe
biden gave us an optimistic joint
address to congress but we're waiting to
see some action
now what's in his plan well
at this point he wants to spend six
trillion dollars on
all kinds of things that would include
fixing up the roads of the country
securing the bridges of the country
power plants uh water treatment
facilities and
the country is really in need of this uh
i don't know
we're gonna say that sounds all good
news to me
indeed indeed i mean look i mean for for
the past several decades the country has
just been decaying we have
municipalities
across the united states that are in
shambles
they're literally unpaving the roads
they actually have this
machine they call a reclaimer that pulls
up the asphalt
pulverizes it and replaces a paved road
with dirt road i cannot i kid you not
and in a number of states throughout the
united states you have municipalities
that are so bankrupt
they cannot afford to maintain paved
roads and we are unpaving our roads you
know while
in developing countries like like china
and nicaragua they are
they are paving new roads uh we in the
united states supposedly the richest
country in the world are unpaving our
roads i mean
we saw the disaster a few years back
with the drinking water in flint
michigan
uh we've seen power plants that just
collapsed that happened in texas you
know the power grid just just
popped this summer and and and left
people throughout the state uh without
electricity in the freezing cold
you know we have a big infrastructure
problem while our government has been so
interested in investing in bombs and
tanks and drones and
weapons of mass destruction and military
spending and military bases around the
world
america has been left behind and both
both previous presidents
obama and trump both promised they were
going to do something about it
and didn't so now we will see if biden
will actually do something about it
but this six trillion dollar plan has
got his
own party divided uh it's got the
republicans up in arms uh they are
talking about all kinds of compromises
that will happen
i'm waiting to see what actually happens
uh with this plan
now you mentioned kamala harris and her
walk jokes
uh that sounds entirely in character to
me
uh tell us about them and how it's gone
down
well we have a situation where it seems
pretty apparent
that the u.s military in particular the
upper ranks the u.s military brass
and the white house are not on the same
page about this kind of
woke makeover for the united states you
know a lot of the military brass are
conservative
folks christian evangelical christianity
is very big among them
they are traditional they certainly
don't want their kids going to school
and reading howard zinn's people's
history of the united states
but yet it seems like in particular the
intelligence apparatus has argued that
the united states
needs a woke makeover we need to show
the world that we are the most
anti-racist the most pro-lgbt country in
the world that we go around
liberating people from regimes that are
too uptight and conservative
so while the intelligence apparatus and
the media has decided we're going to
have a woke makeover to to make
imperialism look hip
uh at the same time we have a military
brass
that doesn't see things that way and has
a very different narrative of world
events
um so kamala harris goes to you know
speak to the navy graduates uh and her
jokes just fall flat
and then you know we're heading this is
memorial day weekend tomorrow is
memorial day the day we commemorate
those who died
in wars uh and you know we have kamala
harris tweeting out uh instead of
you know instead of honoring memorial
day we have her tweeting out uh enjoy
the long weekend uh
uh you know and people are seeing that
as a subtle dig at the military
look there's long been a division within
the u.s structure and government
apparatus
between the military industrial complex
which is a huge part of the u.s
economy and you know the farc folks that
come out of harvard
and yale and the intelligence apparatus
the council on foreign relations
that strategically plan out how to
market the united states around the
world and
covertly push soft power and those two
wings of the american
apparatus the american government the
american deep state if you want to use
those terms
uh they have long been at odds there's
been a lot right written about that
about you know the anglo-american
establishment etc
um and we're seeing these differences
play out and the fact that kamala harris
didn't go over so well
with the navy graduates is just yet
another incident in this long
long standing disagreement beneath the
surface now when
history or the history of this recent
period
comes to be written one of the most
bizarre of many
bizarre episodes will be the extent to
which
so many people in america came to
believe
that donald trump was somehow an agent
of russia this despite the fact
that donald trump caused more trouble
for russia
than virtually any other president
imposed more sanctions
threatened germany uh with the condemned
punishment
for having the temerity in its own
interest to have a pipeline
uh for its gas supply from russia
and so on the the nordstream 2 project
in fact trump was
wildly anti-russian in his actions
and he was mercilessly flayed by the
democratic establishment as
such in politics and in the media
perhaps even especially in the media
how they're handling the fact that
joe biden has now ended the threat
of sanctions on the nord stream and will
shortly meet
uh the aforementioned vladimir putin
well this points to kind of a
long-standing
irony in american politics look richard
nixon
he went and met with mao in china and
why did nixon the conservative
the right winger who took power on a
platform of you know going after the
black liberation struggle and opposing
the peace movement
why is it that he's the one that met
with mao
it's because no democrat would ever get
away with such a thing a democrat would
have been
called a communist and a traitor for
meeting with mao so nixon
a conservative republican whose right
wing and anti-communist credentials were
were very high he was able to do it
and you can see that parallel donald
trump took office being accused of being
you know quote putin's puppet
russia gate hysteria so on that basis we
saw
trump constantly trying to prove trying
to prove how anti-russian he was
ripping up nuclear treaties i mean very
dangerous you can talk about the you
know the short-range treaty
and and the various agreements nuclear
agreements that that he ripped up
you can talk about the attack on germany
and nordstrom
2. um you know the trump administration
was constantly on the defensive when it
came to anything related
to russia meanwhile biden took office
accusing donald trump of being you know
being soft on russia
you know saying all kinds of nasty
things about about russia
and now biden is in office and we're
seeing
suddenly the nuclear treaties are not
being allowed to expire
um you know we're seeing the possibility
of a you know there's going to be a
summit
soon between the two leaders between
putin and biden
um and it seems like because biden is
not on the defensive that gives him a
little bit more of a free hand
to possibly negotiate and improve
relations and this is
the long-standing irony of american
politics uh you know people do the
opposite of what they are accused of
doing
i i genuinely don't want to be too
disrespectful
to your president but many people
in your country and elsewhere i think
will be skeptical
as to what extent president biden is
capable of having
a proper summit uh with vladimir putin i
mean it's
the greatest uh mismatch since rocky
marciano fought
jack bordell isn't it indeed indeed
uh you know uh biden is tripping over
his words
and seems a little bit tired and
everyone knows that
russian president vladimir putin is a
smooth actor i mean he doesn't he
doesn't miss a word
everything is very careful and sharp and
to the point so
it'll be certainly a contrast in styles
and approaches uh
when the two of them are standing next
to each other well
so was rocky marciano versus jack
bordell and ended
with jack horizontal caleb moppen thank
you as
always for a wonderful tour of the
horizon
in the united states politics thank you
for
joining me uh now patrick christie's
our british media and political
commentator
will be up after the
break how's the poll going uh
carrie simon's marriage to boris johnson
uh congratulations up one she got lucky
still at seven percent i'd love to know
uh who the seven percent are
uh that see it that way and 31 down one
say it was a whitewash
let me take just a 60 second break count
them
radio sputnik
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't
take any sides radio sputnik
telling the untold
the airwaves this savannah
is a rigid dictory of fact
and fiction as fisher says the
twittersphere where the slightest
misjudgment can spell
being cancelled
[Applause]
one species rules over the airwaves
through its ability to adapt and survive
and even the harshest environments
the george gateway
[Music]
the top cat in these parts it is mostly
active on sunday
evenings in britain and mid-afternoon
in the united states it's seldom roars
during the day most notable
for its wide variety of headdress it
protects these parts from the mainstream
media
you can catch this fine specimen on the
mother
of all talk shows
don't pick a fight with it they've been
known to bite
back
you're listening to radio sputnik
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
two truths says tim one the world war
ii generation that we commemorated
colonel tom
ettel last year were killed off
in the care homes just think about that
and two the poor people on the minimum
wage
kept the country going during the
lockdowns
very good point and uh angela powell
says did you hear aleister campbell on
sky news this morning
he had the nerf to accuse boris johnson
of being responsible
for tens of thousands of coveted deaths
he may or may not be right with that
but he's obviously forgotten about the
role he played leading up to and during
the iraq war what a hypocrite that's uh
actually sorry i beg your pardon from
gary in
south wales well i'll tell you what gary
once he sees my film on the strange
death of dr
david kelly on the 17th of july
he won't be quite so insouciant about
that
and uh anthony says professor cronin
you don't have to travel to venus to
find
weird life and uh resolute
says um we kieran
let's get married yes my darling that
will distract them
uh resolute says they needed you needed
another option
on your poll for simply don't care
and dave says i don't get that take
he skinned with ccjs to his name
i better explain that to the
international audience
uh dave is saying that boris johnson
is broke he doesn't have any money and
he's got court orders
against them uh for debts but that's
actually a
bit of a stretch uh it wasn't really his
debt and it was a political thing
now this is dave's point and it's been
made
by many people today on social media
including here on the show
i don't care about boris johnson's
marriage except i don't think the church
should have let him marry in church and
or
a cathedral due to his poor marriage
parenting and fidelity history
and uh raj unsworth on the same subject
says boris johnson's wedding was a kick
in the teeth
for the many divorced catholics some of
them women
who escaped abusive relationships who
were not permitted
to have a church wedding and explanation
is owed from the catholic
hierarchy now that's a
series of fair points and before i
answer it
i'm going to ask if norma in bristol
wants to talk about boris's wedding
because if she does i'd like to deal
with them all three
in one go norma
hello george nice to hear from you again
go ahead
um well it's about the catholic church
really yeah
um it's now so open-minded
you know that it's got the third
marriage ceremony of our prime minister
i know his previous marriages were
outside of the catholic church
but surely it would have been better to
have a registry office ceremony do you
think
with a blessing from the catholic church
like prince charles did
um in the anglican church he was he's a
defender of this fight
well we've now got for the very first
time in
our history a catholic prime minister
and it's already causing a great deal of
fluttering in the
duff courts this by the way
61 years after the united states
had its first catholic president now
the similarity between jack kennedy and
boris johnson
probably ends there at least from my
political
standpoint but it's got to be good news
that finally a
a catholic has become prime minister of
britain
it's got to be good news that that
unlike tony blair
uh they didn't have to hide it uh
because blair of course
waited till he'd left office to formally
uh convert to catholicism and we are now
seeing today a large number
of proscriptions of things that boris
johnson
will not now be able to do because he's
outed himself
as a catholic that shows that our
country is still in the dark ages
on these things norma yeah no that's
fine i have no problem with that
whatsoever
and i think that's a good thing it's
more open-minded but
you know george if the catholic church
could now agree
to marry gay and lesbian people it would
give them respect and happiness
it will never do that but you're right
to identify
uh that it is unusual to say the least
uh that a man with the marital
and sexual and parental
record of boris johnson was allowed to
get married not just in church
but in the cathedral and i don't think
you can
separate that from the point i've just
made it is
a matter of historic importance i mean
through the glass right now is my
grandson
sean he was the first
roman catholic baptized in a roman
catholic
ceremony inside the houses of parliament
since oliver cromwell
that's how long it had been before a
catholic child was allowed
to be baptized in the house of commons
now he's a
strapping young man and a student of
great
promise uh so that's why the church
did it is the point i'm making to you
yeah i
i i i can't because of the historic
importance of it
yeah i can see your point and i'm
totally with that point because
i don't think our royal family can marry
no they can't
in fact those that have have had to
change their religion
yeah tomorrow to the royal family but
it's just
i don't know when you say there's all
sorts of things in the bible and
you know fornication to sin isn't it but
they don't like the sin
of lesbians and gay people in the
catholic church no
there's plenty of other churches there's
plenty of other churches that uh welcome
i don't know the anglican isn't very
good
the church of england has as many as as
many gay vicars
yeah it has straight ones i think that
they don't perform the ceremony do they
well you know but you know you know more
than me i thought they were
afraid no they might give it a blessing
they might give it a blessing but they
don't
fully walk forgive my ignorance
on that well a church that was founded
on the on the genitals of henry the
eighth
you'd think would be quite open-minded
uh on that
matters but anyway here's here's my
uh point to you and to david and to raj
okay and you made it yourself earlier uh
these previous marriages of boris
johnson never existed
according to the catholic church because
they were not
catholic marriages so from the point of
view
of the church these divorces rather
uh never existed so there was no bar
on that dave makes the point and he's
got a good point
that someone who's actually wrecked
other people's marriages
as well as wrecked his own he should
think himself jolly lucky that he got to
marry
in westminster cathedral i think we can
all agree on that norma
oh yes i know george it's um
i've been and forgot my thread now i was
listening to you
um so i forgot my thread
women i always claim that they forget
the thread because they've been
listening to me
thank you very much indeed norman thank
you very very nice
to uh talk to you i think
that in a minute or two i'll be able to
get uh patrick christie so
maui bill says aliens are very wisely
keeping their distance from us and i
can't blame them that's a good cue
to go to patrick christie's patrick
welcome back to the show i'm sorry we're
socially distant tonight
i know that you have many important uh
things that you have to do this week so
i'm glad you could fit me in
at all uh the aliens are keeping their
distance from us
because life on earth is just too weird
and it was a pretty weird week wasn't it
yeah it was a pretty weird week although
having seen dominic cohen's testimony i
didn't wonder whether or not aliens were
indeed amongst us actually george for a
period of time there
dominic comings of course uh when
nuclear didn't see really and i thought
that was
quite extraordinary making a series of
uh quite serious allegations the big
question mark is going to be whether or
not of course
any of it's really true and how much we
believe a man who sat in the rose garden
and
lied to us so easily and comfortably in
relation to barnard castle and testing
his eyesight i spoke to
conservative mp andrew bridgen yesterday
who told me he described dominic
cummings
as the kind of man he would go on your
stag do and then run breathlessly to
your fiance
and tell her all the gory details that
so i thought that kind of
sums up what dominick cummings's view is
like uh in the house of parliament now
and amongst
conservative mps but as i'm sure we'll
get stuck into yep several pretty fruity
allegations that matt hancock should
have been sacked 15 to 20 times
especially
i think a lot of people i think a lot of
people might agree with that one
yeah yeah i think that's that's an
element of this i can believe that matt
hancock is not quite
up to the task that said being health
minister in a time of a pandemic is no
easy task anywhere but the notion is the
notion is according to dominant comings
that matt hancock actually was
fundamentally dishonest how hancock
denies this
was that uncle was fundamentally
dishonest when it came to people being
sent back into cairns
and what he knew vis-a-vis them
essentially not being given corona virus
tests
or having had a corona virus test and
testing positive
still being sent back into care homes of
course corona virus ripped through care
homes
at the start of this pandemic and was
that on our health secretary that's the
question
um the other element to dominic cummings
is uh uh dire tribe i suppose is that
boris
is not up to the task and that he didn't
take coronavirus seriously
even after he had the virus now that i
can believe to an extent but i think
what really kind of supposed to take
away from me was that
boris johnson clearly clearly clearly
was so reluctant
to want to enforce all of these
lockdowns or at least that's the message
that's coming out and it's no surprise
george that boris johnson in the
immediate aftermath of dominic cummings
statement there went up six points in
the polls
yes very interesting uh and uh to
i think we can say it might come back to
haunt him but i think we can say
he's home free from the dominic cummings
uh
offensive which is quite peculiar
in a way given perhaps that's the
explanation
given how one note the media have been
about cummings performance almost one
note
uh certainly amongst the liberal
chattarati
the bbc and so on it was as if comings
had come down from the mount with the
truth
uh chiseled into stone and yet
uh johnson's gone up not down in the
opinion polls
yeah this is it i i think the idea now
if you can remember back to a time
essentially i suppose this time last
year really where
we were being told that dominic cummings
was in charge boris was in his pocket
boris was just a puppet a poodle as it
were and actually dominic cummings was
running the country
well now we're being told why didn't
boris johnson just do what dominic
cummings told him to do and you can't
have that both ways one of only one of
those things
can be right and the media needs to make
its mind up there as to which one of
those
it believes to be true boris johnson's
base i suppose and indeed a lot of
people now
i think i'm fair enough for me to say
this really around the country are
are sick and tired of lockdowns uh and
the notion that boris johnson was
potentially one of the only people
who was quite quite reluctant to thrust
us into a never-ending cycle of
lockdowns
actually dealing quite a lot good with
his base and i thought
dominic cummings let himself down
slightly and showed potentially his true
colors in the way that he spoke about
carrying boris johnson's now wife of
course where did that come from
but um he refused to call her by name
and he refused to call boris johnson's
fiancee instead
he kept referring her to her rather
disdainfully as forrest his girlfriend
which i thought
was a bit of a slight there and kind of
showed his true colors in that respect
and did sell out quite quite quite funny
stories again yes
it was uh it was a tad uh
mean uh to do that
especially as they have a child together
and they live in downing street together
which
is pretty groundbreaking even in my
lifetime the idea that someone
could live uh in downing street with
their then girlfriend is quite
uh extraordinary now you correctly
identified
that dominic cummings if if if aliens
are amongst us
they might look like him he is a very
martian looking fellow with a martian
brain they
say uh is he finished now
or does he have more in his locker well
it's finished potentially in more ways
than one i don't think he's finished
talking i'm not sure we'll ever be
finished talking but she'll never be
finished tweeting however i think he'd
have to be from another planet to follow
some of his twitter threads i would urge
everyone now
or so some point after your show george
to go and just try to follow what
dominic cummings is going on about
on his own twitter page it's incredibly
difficult to do i think he might be
finished
in a sense professionally it's a brave
man that employs dominick cummings now a
man who thinks
no for no second whatsoever about going
absolutely nuclear and revealing
essentially all the state secrets are
going to say
what would he do if he was just head of
a think tank you know you don't want to
be in those hr meetings with cummings do
you so
i can imagine that being very difficult
for him look it's whether or not i
suppose he wants to end up doing the
rounds and go on things like i'm a
celebrity to get me out of here
i suspect he'll write a book and i do
suspect as well that'll be potential for
him
going forward he kept his options open
he had his eye on the next man russia
soon knocking on michael go because he's
previously worked for michael go
and he was actually quite complimentary
about those people and so i do wonder
whether or not he wonders if he can have
a route back into power essentially work
back into downing street with those two
but like i said i think he's a brave man
who gives him a job personally
now where are you at the wedding the
secret wedding
are you invited not at all no no
where did that come from they it was a
master stroke of
uh secrecy uh the media
uh didn't get uh wind of it and everyone
had been led to believe
that for some reason they were waiting
till next year
well actually there's quite an
interesting uh under story as it were
running along this it was of course
carrie simons carrie johnson as she is
now known
it used to be uh in a relationship with
harry cole who was the editor of uh
up at the sun and that story about the
wedding taking place in
a year or two's time came out via harry
cole and so whether or not
there's been some deliberate underhand a
man who has now of course now had to
report on his own
uh x's marriage to the prime minister uh
and also simultaneously getting his
story wrong he's probably not putting on
a great day out for old harry who is
normally uh relatively on the mark with
things
and so yeah they keep it they keep it
incredibly quiet a supposedly intimate
ceremony but it has caused a lot of
controversy hasn't it
how can a man twice divorced be married
in a catholic church george you know and
so apparently
why i'm hearing is that the my
understanding is that the catholic
church has decided
not to recognize his previous marriages
which i think is quite convenient isn't
it
yes but uh the real reason is because
for the first time in our history
because of course
we've only had prime ministers uh for a
couple of centuries
uh two and a half um
we've got a catholic prime minister yeah
that's something
that we never thought we might see in
the
uh in this period i didn't realize he
was catholic i've got to be honest with
you i
just didn't i didn't i'm assuming as
well he might be able to uh to claim
some kind of greek orthodox lineage or
something even like that as well with
his with his family
but um he was
he was a catholic at school and
then he defected he's quite uh
how shall i say promiscuous boris
johnson
in religious matters and others
he became an anglican and then
when he met carrie who is a catholic he
converted
back again and the church has forgiven
that uh
promiscuity and other things
precisely because we know britain has
in 2021 a catholic prime minister
when the u.s had its first catholic
president
in 1960 61 years ago
has that caused any free song in
conservative circles
so well i spoke to peter bone earlier
today actually and he was just quite
confused now
what i do find very interesting is
there's two different noises coming out
amongst conservative mps
says what you're getting on twitter and
what you're getting online which is warm
wishes
we wish them well we're so delighted for
you what's a fabulous couple
nothing is ever going to go wrong here
and then you have behind the scenes
which is actually people
already sniffling a little bit and
saying there's no way this is going to
last
how come they've ended up in this
situation is it a case where boris
has maybe been a little bit of a silly
boy and perhaps has got himself into a
situation where it's really
the right thing for the country and for
the dignity of his office if you could
call it that that actually
should be you know what committed
marriage essentially with with an
individual and
so that seems to be the two different
move musics among conservative mps the
actual
catholicism element to i've certainly
not heard anything um
along those lines apart from just
genuine confusion as to how he was able
to actually get married in a catholic
church yeah
it's just if you look at joshua
rosenberg's legal blog
you'll see a long list of things that
the prime minister will not
now be legally able to do like
nominating bishops and so on
and many other things because british
law
still forbids roman catholics from
doing these things having these powers
like being in the royal family for
example if you're a catholic
marrying into the royal family if you
were of a mind
you'd probably be best advised not to
but if you were
you would have to relinquish your faith
in order to
do so so it is uh a bit of a historic
uh event oh absolutely you know it
is definitely a story command i like the
idea now that boris has probably had
a little bit too much on his plate for
quite a while could hide behind the
catholicism excuse now to essentially do
a bit less work
i do wonder if that was on his mind at
all but no i think it's um
i think he's definitely historic in that
sense and it's also i think just
probably the right thing for the country
for boris johnson to have actually done
um i think the question marks are just
over
um really i don't think that carrie is
particularly popular behind the scenes
she isn't really particularly popular
behind the scenes
amongst staff in downing street and
amongst fellow conservative mps
for some reason whether or not this is
unfair it may well be unfair
she is treated with with an element of
skepticism she's seen us uh wanting to
adopt causes that are not regarded as
being particularly positive amongst the
conservative base environmentalism
being one of those and there are
concerns about how much of boris is if
she has someone of a better phrase you
would imagine now
quite a lot uh and so there are there
are concerns over that and there also
are concerns coupled with that about
whether or not boris is fundamentally
quite a weak man when it comes to women
and whether or not she does have an
undue influence over him that said i
suppose any man is going to listen to
his wife at some point isn't he so
uh you know you could argue that that's
uh that that's reasonable um so yeah
there are there is some suspicion with
carrie and i think as well look dominick
cummings i know we started talking about
cummings and it's it's fitting we
kind of come full circle in this sense
really because he did uh he did
crown her princess nut nut which i think
is incredibly derogatory don't get me
wrong
but then did reference in the um in the
inquest in the inquiry it was part of a
situation where
we were about to announce that we were
going to throw everyone into full
lockdown it was that day donald trump
wanted to join a bombing campaign in
iraq
and carrie simon's got the downing
street press office to focus entirely
pretty much on a story in the times
about whether or not she was going to
give dylan the dog away and i think that
just maybe show uh
where where some issues could emerge
behind the scenes vis-a-vis carrie and
boris
well we'll keep a close eye on it uh
thanks to you uh
patrick christie's thanks for joining us
on board
the mother of all talk shows let's go to
simon in preston on ufos go ahead simon
about ufos i'm i'm just ringing to do
with my
my two penis on um on intelligent life
in the universe
you're right i i shouldn't have put it
the way i did go ahead
no no no it's fine so my uh view is
very much from a scientific point of
view that you know it's never
aliens until it's aliens and the old
adage of
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof and
certainly to my mind and all the
evidence that i've seen there is
absolutely no evidence today that any of
the
so-called sightings of alien life and
alien transport
um or anything more than just um
um as the scientist right on before uh
was saying that are just um
digital remnants you know that are on a
camera screen you know you very often
hear them saying oh it's moving it
it's moving at hundreds of thousands
well i say thousands of miles an hour
and i can see
on my screen but there's no radar
contact what's because it just doesn't
actually exist that's why there's no
radar well it could be
but it could be being covered up isn't
that the point simon
and isn't that what we're beginning to
see
break down now in the united states uh
because according to obama
uh there were lots uh or there is
lots of evidence of extraordinary
things unexplained things but they just
don't release that
to the public for obvious reasons
yeah there's lots of things in the world
people people do things don't we that
you know
you know you say why on earth would you
have done that you know actually it's
completely unexplainable
don't mean to say it didn't happen all
that it did it should you know
you know these things are just a lot of
them are just as fantable anyway what i
was going to say as well was a little
bit more is that
um in terms of um the distance to
you know other stars where the weather
potential the planets around
a hundred light years of the earth there
was only 800 stars
so there's not necessarily going to be
that many planets and if you imagine
that we've been transmitting
at the very most electronic signals for
100 years
then it can't have got more than um
it can't have got further than those 800
stars what we've transmitted
and likewise signals can't have got
towards from
well our electronic signals might be
much weaker than
any extraterrestrial life oh that's
irrelevant the fastest that you can
the fastest that anything can travel is
the speed of light in electronic signals
electronic signals if you're a human on
earth as if you're a human or
no no no
that's the point that uh was being made
by pope uh that you have to imagine a
new
you'll only get in physics physics in
the new universe
well you know and there is there
are signs behind things
that are dreamt of in your philosophy
horatio you mustn't imagine that
life has to look like us
even going back to professor cronin that
life
is formed biologically
at all uh i'm absolutely sure that it
doesn't look like us george but i'm
absolutely sure that it conforms to the
rules of physics in our universe
well the the rules as defined by us
from here in
these craft can be coming from not
uh not uh even necessarily in our solar
system
they can be coming from distant solar
systems
physics where a different physics may
exist
no no no no no no there's no other
physics of what the physics we know in
the universe that's what makes them
these are all potentially uh changing
script changing physics changing
uh phenomena they are but there's no
evidence for them at the moment
before for translating that the absence
of evidence
is not evidence of absence
but going back to my previous point that
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence sure i mean i
could make any claim it doesn't mean to
say that it's true
no that's that's obviously the case
but i like to employ
uh a certain logical test
and it's this what would be the reason
for all of this universe
to exist but only one
really rather insignificant planet to
have
ever had any form of life on it
that science absolutely that sounds
completely logical
i absolutely agree with you george and i
really
i really really want it to be aliens but
until it's aliens it's not aliens
okay in actual fact i don't know if
you've seen the film contact actually
because there you said the same line
that you just made and it was amazing
it is an awful waste of space if
if we are all that there is exactly
thanks simon i've enjoyed that call
michael
is the last caller maybe no we might get
another one in
michael in minneapolis uh on bernie
sanders and u.s politics
go ahead michael hey george how are you
doing today good i've enjoyed the show i
hope you have
absolutely so i just want to talk about
sort of where the democratic party is is
and what they're doing right now
so you know during when joe biden passed
the covid relief bill
um he abandoned several campaign
promises
and with no opposition from
you know the progressives in congress
bernie or the squad he refused to put in
a 15
minimum wage which as you remember in
that last one-to-one
debate back in march with joe biden
um joe biden absolutely unequivocally
promised he would go to the mat for a 15
minimum wage well that didn't happen we
didn't get any
rent or mortgage relief we didn't get
any sort of expanded stimulus we didn't
get anything really for small business
owners
and then this past week they debated on
a bill
to increase capital
uh police budget by nearly 2 billion
with a b dollars and you've got to
remember you know after
george floyd and everything and all the
protests of last summer
the squad was banging the drum for you
know defund the police
they need to you know reform the police
and we can't put so much money into it
and you know they were that was a huge
thing that they were very focused on
um and that the progressive young base
of this country that was out in the
streets marching was focused on
and this past week when it came though
to vote for themselves
so they're talking about defunding the
police for other people but when it came
to themselves
um three of them you know it was a party
vote perhaps they just want to get
re-elected
michael anyone
uh who would be found
to have actually defunded the police
would be electoral uh
electorally radioactive
well that's one thing george but we're
talking about the capitol police so this
is just in washington dc
so three members of the squad voted no
which is what they had said they would
do
but then three of them including jamal
bowman and alexandria ocasio-cortez
and rashida talib all voted
present so their rhetoric has been let's
you know defund the police but when it
came to themselves
uh they voted for a two billion dollar
increase to the capital police that's
just in washington d.c
for one police force for one police
force
two billion extra yeah two billion
additional funding wow which is going to
make the capital less accessible
um to the general public and also
increases
sort of the surveillance states um you
know
uh oversight into it and it's just
unbelievable hypocrisy for them
it passed george by one vote 213 to 212.
so if any of the three and voted against
it it would have gone down
and you know i don't think yes the
capital police should they stop people
from riding the capital
sure but that wasn't the issue the issue
wasn't that there weren't enough police
the issue was that they weren't you know
they weren't
tossed into action because frankly
donald trump wasn't that upset
about the capital you know protest riot
so they don't need any more money but it
just it's just
the hypocrisy is just and you know at
the same time
they're not taking a stand for anything
i guess that's why i'm so worked up and
frustrated
is because america's falling apart we
desperately need
all that kind of coveted relief that we
just haven't gotten
and what they're focused on is let's
increase money for the capitol police
force and they're talking about how they
want to investigate
the capital riots on the sixth like it's
the most important thing that ever
happened
yeah it was that country that was
offering foreign an insurrection don't
you know
michael thank you very much indeed yeah
for that call samuel is in new york
go ahead samuel hello george it's an
honor to speak to you i
i started first hearing you at on wbai
here in new york and i was also called
the mother of all
talk shows well remembered yes
and uh i've been uh a follower a
follower ever since i
i also was listening to um your speech
and a couple of your speeches at the
oxford union the one
that the one that said where that's on
youtube is
is that where the the excuse me student
asks you
are you a racist and then you you give
him a great answer
you said that you would never debate uh
a supporter of
israeli apartheid how how does that
relate in your mind to what we've just
seen
the horrible incidents uh in in
in gaza today recently well
i i discuss with israelis all the time
in fact
gideon levy uh whom i call the greatest
living
israeli is a regular guest on the show a
journalist from
haaretz who supports justice and
humanity
in israel but having been an activist
in the anti-apartheid struggle in south
africa
if you'd asked me back when mandela was
in jail
and apartheid was standing on the necks
of the
majority population in south africa to
have a gentlemanly scholarly
student union debate with a supporter of
that system
i would have refused and if that's so
how can i justify a scholarly
student debate with a supporter of
apartheid
in israel palestine i can't um
but that's not to say i don't talk to
israelis
i do all the time some of my best
friends as they say
are israelis but they're not supporters
of what is happening to the palestinian
people
that's the difference sam yes
i really really appreciate your answer
uh george and uh
i just hope that i could follow in your
footsteps in the future
god bless you thank you for the call uh
gerard
in kill winning is definitely the lot
the last call
gerard go ahead yes george listen if you
want another job the celtic manager
job's still going so uh
an australian guy for that oh god i
don't know george apparently
some guy who's worked in japan and
australia i've never heard of them i
must say
i've never heard of them but not big on
um
coaches working in japan but it doesn't
fill me
it doesn't fill me with great excitement
maybe we should have kier starmer's job
uh george i don't think he could do much
worse for celtic as he's doing for
labour you know
i wouldn't wish uh that on
any football team certainly not celtic
uh
it is a terrible mess labor and celtic
it really is george and the thing about
star wars like i'm not going to hold him
responsible for everything
this goes back you mentioned touchdown
iraq if you all the way back to the
airport
guys like you and the late great robin
cook stood up and said no
to this uh monstrosity that took place
but you go back to even jeremy corbyn
from the day
he got in the door the playwrights the
right wingers
were campaigning against them they were
trying to stab him in the back
immediately
and the country saw this and the people
saw this they thought wait a minute
if you're not even going to stand by
your own leader who the party the people
of your party elected
why in god's name are you going to stand
up for us they don't trust the labour
party no and they don't see this jaws
the labour elites don't understand
that the way they treated jeremy corbyn
is going to haunt him for
a long time to come yes that's right
jeremy corbyn of course himself also
made many mistakes but
it is important to remember
that notwithstanding two whole years
of insurrection against their own leader
corbyn got the best labor vote
the biggest increase in the labor vote
since 1945
at the general election in 2017.
corbin bought for less than three and a
half thousand votes
would have been the prime minister of
britain
exactly and he was actually the
antithesis of tony blair
and your david milibands and your
mandelsons and all these other
characters
who you know went labour they just used
labour for their own agenda
starmar must go the australian coach
i don't know what to say i don't want to
be disloyal
i've got a hail hail anyways thanks hill
health to you
gerard in kill winning in ershad in
scotland only one scottish call
today time was when all the calls were
scottish
but we have toured the american
continent from brazil
to canada and
it's been marvelous for me i hope it was
for you and if it was
come back next week at the same time
same place
for the mother of all talk shows good
night
[Music]
you